hello everyone and welcome to an
introduction to data structures
my name is stephen and over the next
three hours we'll be tackling the topic
of data structures in relation to
computer science
more specifically we'll be talking about
what they are
going over some different types of data
structures and discussing how we can use
each of them effectively with examples
this course will be a general overview
of data structures and so we won't be
confining ourselves to one specific
programming language
however this series will require you to
have a basic understanding of
programming
if you are completely new to computer
science i would recommend our
introduction to programming series which
will be linked in the description below
that video will give you all the
information you need to traverse these
topics comfortably
now we're almost ready to hop into
things however there are a few
housekeeping items that i want to go
over beforehand for those wishing to
enhance their learning experience
if you're not interested in that and
want to skip right to the content
go to the time shown on your screen now
for those of you staying though
there are just a few things i would like
to mention firstly
in the description you will find time
stamps for each major topic covered in
this video
as well as time stamps taking you to
every smaller section contained within
those topics
so please feel free to skip around if
you are already comfortable with one
topic or
only interested in a certain data
structure
next we've decided to include the script
and visuals used for the series
also in the description below that way
you can follow along if you like or
simply read the script if my soothing
voice isn't your style
additionally for each segment i'll be
including the references and research
materials used to write the script for
each topic
that way if you ever feel as if i
haven't explained a topic well enough
or would just simply like more
information about a certain topic
you'll have a readily made list of
articles and websites which you can use
to supplement this series
if you feel like you have any questions
throughout the series about maybe
something i said or a certain visual
please ask your questions in the
comments below i'll try to be as
responsive as possible for the first few
weeks on questions you guys may have
about the series and such
and finally in terms of housekeeping i'd
just like to say if you're not already
subscribed to our channel
no point or exception then consider
doing so if you enjoy this type of
content
as me and my co-host sean regularly post
videos in his style
we're trying to hit 1 000 subscribers
before the fall semester of college
begins
so check us out if you end up enjoying
the video with my shameless plug out of
the way we're finally ready to tackle
the topic of data structures
in this introduction segment we'll
simply cover a general overview of what
data structures are
and then go over what type of
information will be covered throughout
the duration of this series
so the obvious question to start with is
what exactly is a data structure
well in computer science a data
structure is a way to store
organize and manage information or data
in a way that allows you the programmer
to easily access or modify the values
within them
essentially it's a way for us to store a
set of related information
that we can use for our programs
data structures and the algorithms used
to interact modify
and search through them provide the
backbone for many of the programs that
you'll end up writing
i can almost guarantee that in 99 of
your programs
a data structure will be involved each
of the data structures that i'll be
talking about
are designed for the sole purpose of
storing information and allowing the end
user to access and manipulate that
information
in an efficient and effective way but
each one differs in the manner that they
accomplish this
if you have a basic understanding of
programming you probably know about a
few different data structures already
such as the array and the array list
also known as the list in python
but if you're going to be pursuing a
career in computer science
just knowing these two is definitely not
going to cut it
while basic data structures such as the
array are used frequently by companies
throughout their code
more advanced data structures are being
put to use all around you
the undo redo button in google docs
google maps on your phone
even the auto complete feature through
your text messages all require the use
of more advanced data structures
which makes them extremely useful to
learn and comprehend
okay now i can't see you per se but i
can just tell that you're jumping up and
down in your seat
hooked on data structures and how useful
they can be
but before we jump too far into things
let's discuss the information that we'll
be covering in this series
now before we talk about any specific
data structures we're going to have a
brief talk about
efficiency we'll discuss the metrics
used to judge the speed and efficiency
of different data structures
which will then give you a better
understanding of why one data structure
might be used over another one from
there we'll start by diving headfirst
into what i believe are the basic data
structures those being arrays and array
lists
while you may already have a good
understanding of what these are
i would highly suggest that you still
watch these segments because we'll be
going into a little bit more depth as to
why they're so useful
based on differences in how they're
stored in the computer's memory
after that we'll move on to what i'll
call the intermediate data structures
these are a little bit more complicated
than the basics and have a few special
attributes which make them stand out
from the rest
we'll begin by taking a look at stacks
which are the backbone for all recursive
processes in your computer
then we'll look at the antithesis of a
stack the queue
moving on from there we'll be covering
linked lists and the revolved form in
the doubly linked list
before moving on to the final of our
intermediate data structures
the dictionary which includes a mini
lesson on hash tables
then we'll wrap up the series talking
about trees and tree based data
structures
less linear and more abstract data
structures beginning with the tree
itself we'll then move on to tries a
very useful data structure used for a
lot of word processing algorithms
and finally end of the series with a
discussion on heaps and graphs
so in total i'll be taking you through
four different segments containing 12 of
the most common data structures that are
practically used
as well as providing examples of where
and when to use them
section 1 on efficiency section 2 on
basic data structures
section 3 on intermediate data
structures and wrapping it up with
section 4 on tree based data structures
with this knowledge you'll be able to
take charge of your programming career
and hopefully gain a competitive edge by
implementing them when needed like i
said however
before we jump straight into the
different ways to store information
i'd like to have a quick discussion on
how we score the efficiency of these
data structures
using what is known as big-o notation so
let's jump right in
okay so before we talk about all these
crazy data structures like
maps and heaps we want a quantifiable
way to measure how efficient a certain
data structure is at the different tasks
we might ask of it
if we're going to be storing extremely
large amounts of data
being able to search through modify
or access the information within a data
structure needs to be fast and efficient
as we briefly mentioned before the
industry standard for this kind of
implementation is big-o notation so what
exactly is big-o notation and
how do we measure it for a specific data
structure
well that's what we'll be covering in
this segment for most of the basic and
intermediate data structures in the
series
we're going to be spending some time
talking about its efficiency
using big o notation so this is
definitely a topic you're not going to
want to skip
with that being said let's begin
so because there are so many different
ways to store information like we talked
about in the previous segment
programmers have developed this idea of
big-o notation
as a way to basically score a data
structure based on a few different
criteria
this criteria can change based on who
you ask but for the purposes of this
video we will be using four criteria
representing the most common functions
you might want from a data structure
the ability to access a specific element
within the data structure
search for a particular element within
the data structure
insert an element into the data
structure and remove an element from the
data structure
now by measuring how efficiently a
certain data structure can do these four
things we can basically create a report
card of sorts which measures how
efficient
a certain data structure is at a glance
this gives us a pretty good
overview of what a certain data
structure is good at and what it is bad
at
and it can help us decide which one to
use if we need to store data that is
easily accessible to the end user for
example
we might choose a data structure which
can access elements the quickest
vice versa if accessing elements isn't
the most important thing to us
but we need a data structure which can
be easily added to and deleted from
we would go for one which is most
efficient in that specific functionality
by looking at a data structure's report
card if you will
we can get a quick sneak peek at what
they're good at and what they are bad at
now if we use big-o notation to
basically create a report card like i
said
there must be some way to actually grade
each of these functions
and there is the four criteria mentioned
accessing searching inserting and
deleting
are all scored using big o notation time
complexity equations
now what is a big o notation time
complexity equation
well i'm glad you asked besides being in
an annoyingly long phrase
a big o notation time complexity
equation or just time complexity
equations
work by inserting the size of the data
set as an integer
n and returning the number of operations
that need to be conducted by the
computer
before the function can finish the
integer
n is simply the size or amount of
elements contained within the data set
so for example if we have an array one
of the data structures we'll get into
soon
with a size of 10 we would place 10 into
the different efficiency equations for
accessing searching inserting and
deleting that represent the array
and returned back to us would be the
number of operations
that need to be conducted by the
computer before completion of that
function
it does get a little bit more
complicated than this but for the sake
of keeping this series simple
all you need to know is that these
equations help represent efficiency
amongst different data structures
also an important thing to note here is
that we always use the worst case
scenario when judging these data
structures
this is because we always want to
prepare for the worst and know which
data structures are going to be able to
perform
under the worst conditions you'll see
what this means in greater detail a
little later on once we start putting
this into practice
but for now just keep in mind that when
judging data structures
we always use the worst case scenario
moving on the reason that it's called
big o notation
is because the syntax for these
particular equations
includes a big o and then a set of
parentheses
inside these parentheses we'll include
some function which will correctly
return the number of operations needed
to be run by the computer
so for example let's say we have a fake
function
it can really be anything the purpose in
this case is irrelevant
now for this fake function let's say its
time complexity
equation was the one shown on your
screen now
we would pronounce this time complexity
equation as o
of 2 meaning it takes two operations
from the computer before our make
believe function can finish
if the time complexity equation was o
with a 5 in the parentheses instead
it would be o of 5 and so on
now these are examples of time
complexity equations which run in
constant time
meaning no matter the size of our data
set it will always take the same number
of instructions to run
this is usually not going to be the case
though when it comes to the four
criteria we want to mention for our data
structures
most of the time our integer n which
again contains the amount of elements
within the data set
is going to have some adverse effect on
how many operations
it takes to say search through our data
structure which makes sense
a larger data set means it's going to
take more operations from the computer
to search through that entire data set
now we score these four functionalities
in number of operations performed
because measuring by how long the
function takes to run would be silly
if we measured by a metric such as time
taken to completion
our results would be highly biased by
the hardware used to run the function
a supercomputer used by google is
obviously going to be able to search
through a data structure much faster
than a laptop
time complexity equations essentially
level the playing field by instead
returning the number of operations
to eliminate the bias in processing
power that exists
so to sum up everything that we've
learned so far
we measure the efficiency or speed of a
data structure
based on how well it can perform four
basic tasks
accessing searching for inserting and
deleting elements within itself
each of these criteria is modeled by an
equation which takes in the size of the
data structure in number of elements
n and returns back the number of
operations needed to be performed by the
computer
to complete that task by measuring these
four metrics we can get a pretty good
understanding of what the data structure
is good at
and what the data structure is bad at
now it's important to note that this
isn't the end all be all for deciding on
which data structure to use in your
program
as you'll see as this video progresses
many of the data structures were
structured with specific quarks or
features
which separate them from the rest and
provide additional functionality
big-o notation is incredibly useful and
something that you should definitely
take into consideration when determining
which data structure to implement into
your program
but it should not be the only thing that
you use
cool now that we know a little bit about
how we measure the efficiency of a data
structure
using time complexity equations along
with the four criteria actually used to
measure them
let's dive straight into what the actual
equations mean in terms of efficiency
that way when we start grading data
structures you'll have a good idea as to
how good or
bad each one is at that particular
metric
basically we're going to cover the six
most common time complexity equations
from most efficient to least efficient
now the absolute best that a data
structure can score
on each criteria is a time complexity
equation of
o of one this essentially means that no
matter what the size of your data set
is the task will be completed in a
single step
if your data set has one element the
computer will finish the task in one
step
if your data set has 100 elements one
one million elements one step 800
quadrillion elements it does not matter
the computer will finish the task in a
single step
this is why when we look at the graph of
volume of data versus instructions
required for o of 1
the line remains constant at 1. no
matter the volume of data stored within
the data structure
the computer can complete that task in a
single instruction
whether it be accessing searching
inserting or deleting
o of 1 is the gold standard absolute
best
top of its class time complexity
equation it is basically the michael
jordan of big o notation
when it comes to time complexity
equations
now the next fastest type of time
complexity equation is
o log n while not as fast as
instantaneous time
a function having a time complexity of o
log n will still provide you with very
fast completion
now if you don't fully understand
logarithms entirely just know that this
efficiency
is slower than instantaneous time o of 1
and faster than the next level of
efficiency known as o of
n additionally because the volume of
data versus time graph follows a
logarithmic curve
the larger the data set that you use the
more bang for your buck that you're
going to get
basically as the amount of data you try
to perform one of our four criteria on
increases the rate of change of the
amount of operations it takes to
complete that certain task
decreases so as you can see
at the beginning of the graph here when
we increase the volume of data
our number of operations skyrockets but
when we do the same for larger and
larger sets of data
our number of operations increases much
more slowly than before
a good example of a non-data structures
related function which has a time
complexity of o log
n is the binary search if you know what
a binary search is then you'll
understand how it is that when the data
set gets larger
the number of instructions needed to
find the item you're searching for
doesn't increase at the same rate if you
don't know what a binary search is but
would like to know in order to better
understand
o login a link in the description below
will take you to that point in our
introduction to programming series where
you can learn about it
if not let's move on to the next
equation
o of n is the next common time
complexity equation that's going to come
up frequently
during this lecture the graph of volume
of data
versus instructions needed for this
function is linear
meaning that for every element you add
to the data set the amount of
instructions needed to complete that
function will increase by the same
amount
so to perform a function with a time
complexity of o of n
on a data set with 10 elements it will
take 10 instructions
50 elements will take 50 instructions 1
000 elements 1 000 instructions and so
on
o n is really the last good time
complexity equation that exists
anything above this is considered
inefficient and not very practical when
it comes to data structures in computer
science
the next type of equation that will come
up is o n
log n this equation is the first that is
relatively bad in terms of efficiency
the graph of volume versus operations
shows a somewhat linear but increasing
graph
meaning unlike o log n it won't be
better in terms of efficiency
as the size of the data set increases
instead the slope actually increases as
the volume of data does
the last two types of equation are on
squared and
o2 to the n these are both incredibly
inefficient
equations which should be avoided if at
all possible
because they are both exponential in
structure which can be seen from their
graphs of volume versus operations
the larger the data set that you use the
more inefficient it will
become while there are more time
complexity equations that exist
such as o n factorial which is even
worse than the two i just mentioned
the data structures we'll be talking
about will never have time complexity
equations
that exist outside of the five we've
just covered so we're going to stop
there
now the final thing i want to say is
just a reiteration of something i said
before
these time complexity equations are not
the only metric you should be using to
gauge which data structure to use
as we get deeper and deeper into this
series you'll see that we might have
some data structures which don't seem
that efficient at all based on their
time complexity equations
but provide some other functionality or
feature which makes them extremely
useful for programmers
okay now that we have some knowledge on
how we actually grade these data
structures
in terms of efficiency let's hop into
our very first data structure
the first data structure we're going to
be covering is the array
now i understand the array is a pretty
common data structure taught in most
programming classes
and that many of you might already know
about the properties and uses of an
array
but in this segment we'll be going into
more detail on the array as a data
structure
including its time complexity equations
storage methods and more
so check the description for a time
stamp to skip ahead to that section if
you already know the basics
if you're not as versed in the array
though or just want a general review
then stick around because right now
we'll be discussing the basics of an
array
an array is fundamentally a list of
similar values grouped together in a
central location
which makes sense because if you
remember we use data structures to store
sets of similar information
so that we can easily use that
information
basically arrays can be used to store
anything
usernames for an app high scores for a
video game
prices for an online shop pretty much
any list of values which are
fundamentally similar
meaning of the same's type so integers
strings floats objects the list goes on
and on
any primitive or advanced data type you
can think of can be stored within an
array
every item contained within the array is
referred to as an
element of that array and we call the
collective total of
elements the array this is going to be
true for almost all data structures we
talk about by the way
so just keep that in mind an array will
also have three
attributes associated with it the first
being a name for the array
the second a type for the array and the
third a size for the array
let's start with the name
the name if you couldn't tell is just
simply a name for the array
which can be used to reference and
interact with it
say for example we had an array called
names which contained a list of company
employees
and then we also had an array called
salaries which contained a list of
salaries for those employees
if we wanted to search through the list
of salaries we would do so by
referencing the salaries array with its
name
this way the computer knows that you
want to search through that specific
array
containing salaries and not the names
array instead
this works vice versa as well of course
if we wanted to search through the names
array instead
now another thing to note really quickly
while we have this up is that these two
arrays are also an example of parallel
arrays
parallel arrays are two or more arrays
containing the same number of elements
and have the property wherein each
element in one array
is related to the element in the other
array or arrays
of the same position so
from our example we can say that the
first element in our names array
john smith corresponds to the first
element in the salary array
the integer ten thousand this would mean
that john smith has a salary of ten
thousand this is really good because as
you'll see later on
we can't store differing types of
variables in the same array
so we couldn't have these salary
integers be stored in the same place as
the name strings
making parallel arrays extremely useful
for storing different types of data
about the same entity all right
tangent over let's get back to the
attributes of arrays
and the second one we'll be talking
about the arrays type
now an array's type is simply what type
of information
is stored or will be stored within that
array
one of the biggest stipulations about
arrays is that it has to hold
all the same type of information so you
cannot have an array containing integers
and strings
it would have to be either an array of
only integers
or only strings this works for any type
of information you would want to store
within the array
meaning every element or spot within the
array must be of the same type
the third and final attribute that an
array has is a size
this size is a set integer that is fixed
upon the creation of the array
it represents the total amount of
elements that are able to be stored
within the array
an array size cannot be changed i'll
repeat that again because it's extremely
important
an array size cannot be changed once
created
once you write the line of code which
instantiates an array
you give it a defined size or fill it
with elements until it has a defined
size
and then at that point the array size
cannot be changed by conventional
methods
this is actually pretty rare for a data
structure and it may seem really
counter-intuitive and useless
but later on when we talk about an
array's efficiency
you'll see that this is for a specific
reason and not just to be annoying to
the programmer
so there you have it the three
attributes of an array
a name to reference it a type to fill it
with
and a size to control it let's now shift
focus and talk about how we actually
define an array ourselves
how we reference and change values
within an array and then dive into the
idea
of two dimensional arrays
there are actually two different ways to
instantiate an array in most languages
you can either populate the array with
elements that you want
contained within it right then and there
or
you can set a specific size for the
array and then slowly populate it later
on as the program runs
we'll be discussing how to do both
starting with the first
creating the array with the elements
already stored
now defining and filling an array as
soon as you create it is mainly used for
when you already know which values are
going to be held within it
for example let's say you're creating an
array which is going to hold the salary
of 10 different workers at a company
and that information is being read in
from a text file
well you already know the 10 salaries
for those workers from the text file
and so you're able to immediately
populate the array when you create it
this way you'll already have the
information available to you as the
program runs
the way you do this varies amongst
different programming languages
but it's shown here in three different
languages java python
and c-sharp to give you a basic gist of
how this is accomplished
all three lines of code on your screen
now will create an
integer array of size 3 containing the
numbers
1 2 and 3. you can see that all of them
involve the declaration of an array name
which is then set equal to the values
you want to include within the array
encapsulated by some sort of brackets or
braces this isn't 100
how it's going to be for all languages
but for the most part it will follow
this skeletal outline
as you can see java and c-sharp require
you to define the array type
whereas python does not but for the most
part the syntax is the same
again that is name of array set equal to
list of comma separated values
encapsulated by brackets or braces
this also develops the size of the array
for you automatically
so since we populate the array with the
numbers 1
2 and 3 the array would instinctively
have a size of 3
as it now contains 3 integers
if we were to say go back and add in a
fourth number
where we define the array the size would
dynamically increase to four
the next time we run the code now the
second way in which we can instantiate
an array
is by setting an initial size for our
array but not filling it with any
elements
and then slowly populating it as the
program runs
this would be used in the case that you
don't actually know what information
you're going to store in the array
but will as the program runs through
the most common case in which this
happens is in the case where the end
user will enter
information into the program and then
that information will be stored inside
the array
since the information varies based on
which user runs the code
and what they input during that
particular run
we have no way of populating the array
as soon as it's instantiated
forcing us to add the information later
shown on your screen now are two ways in
which we can do this
in java and c-sharp now you'll notice
that there is no python section
because of the fact that creating
populate later arrays is not
conventionally possible
in the base version of python without
the use of more advanced data
structures or packages you can see
however
with java and c-sharp that just as with
the other example
there are slight differences in the
syntax on how we do this
but it generally follows some set
pattern
the type of the array followed by a name
for the array
which is then set equal to a size for
the array
remember this size is final and cannot
be changed outside of this initial call
if you end up creating an array with the
size 10
but then later in the program find that
you need more space for it
you can always go back to where you
instantiated it and change the size
but after that line of code runs there
is no conventional way to
increase it you may also be wondering
what the brackets mean when
instantiating an array and that's just a
way to signify to the computer that we
are indeed trying to create an array and
not just a variable
now that we know the two different ways
to instantiate an array
we need to know how we as the programmer
actually get
information that is stored within the
array so that we're able to use it
and the simplest way to answer that
question is through the means of a
numerical
index an index is simply an integer
which corresponds to an element within
the array
now the most important thing to know
about indexes is that for a certain
array
they begin at 0 instead of 1.
so if we have an array of 10 elements
the first
index would actually be index 0.
the second would be index 1 and so on
all the way up to the 9th index
it's a little bit weird at first but
trust me you get used to it
now to retrieve information from a
certain position within the array
you would reference it using both the
array's name and then the index number
of the element you wish to retrieve
say we have our array called numbers
here which contains the integers one
through ten
to print out the element at the fifth
index in this case the number six
we would reference the array name in
this case numbers
and then in a set of brackets we would
place the index we want to retrieve
in this case the number five what this
piece of code is basically telling the
computer
is to print out the fifth index of the
numbers array
which again is the integer six
now because indexes start at zero
instead of one
it's very important to note that to get
the tenth element of the array
you would actually need to reference it
using the number nine
since there is no 10th index
if you do end up making this mistake it
will result in an array out of bounds
error
since there is no 10th index in the
bounds of the numbers array
referencing an array's index number is
how we actually replace elements within
the array as well
continuing with our numbers array let's
say we wanted to change the last element
the integer 10 to be the integer 11
instead
what we would do is reference the ninth
index of the numbers array
the one which currently contains the
integer 10 and set it equal to 11.
this tells the computer to take the
element at index 9
and replace it with the integer 11
essentially swapping 10
for 11. now the last thing i want to
talk about before we jump into the time
complexity equations for an array
is the practice of putting arrays inside
of arrays
an array with an array at each element
is known as a two-dimensional array
think of a two-dimensional array as a
matrix
it's similar to any other array except
for the fact that instead of a primitive
data type like an integer housed at each
element
we would instead have a whole other
array with its own size and indexes
two-dimensional arrays are useful for a
variety of purposes
such as if you were programming a chess
board a bingo board
or even an image where each element in
the two-dimensional array
contains an rgb value which when
combined
creates an image now referencing an
element within a two-dimensional array
is mostly the same as with
one-dimensional arrays
except you now need two indexes the
first number would be the index of the
column that you want to reference
and the second number would be the index
of the row that you want to reference
by combining these two numbers we can
single out an element within the
two-dimensional array
that will then be returned to us as an
example
let's create a two-dimensional array
with 16 names contained within four rows
and four columns
now to access the name carl you'd first
single out the column which contains the
name you're looking for
in this case carl is in the third column
meaning it's in the second index
next you would single out the row which
contains the name you're looking for
in this case the name carl is in the
third row
so we would again use the second index
to reference it
combining these two pieces of
information gives us the index location
2 comma 2. and if you look
carl is indeed at index location 2 comma
2.
just as another example atom is in the
first column
two rows down and so to reference atom
you would simply call upon the element
at index location
zero comma one two dimensional arrays
are just the beginning
you can also have three-dimensional
arrays four-dimensional arrays
and so on for containing large amounts
of advanced relational data
but two-dimension is is where we're
going to stop for today
all right that concludes the background
information on arrays
now that we know what they are let's
actually talk about arrays as a data
structure
this is where we're finally going to be
using our big-o notation knowledge from
the previous segment
to judge the array as a data structure
we'll be going through the four criteria
we talked about previously
accessing elements within an array
searching for an element within an array
inserting an element into an array and
deleting an element from an array
and scoring it based on how effectively
it can complete these four
tasks using time complexity equations
now accessing an element within an array
can be conducted in an instantaneous
o of one time this means that for any
element within your array that you want
to know the contents of
you can do so immediately by simply
calling upon its index location
this has to do with the way that an
array is stored within memory
for example sake let's look at a fake
portion of memory in the computer
you can see we have some information
near the beginning
maybe some integers or strings that
we've initialized
that's not important what's important is
that when we get to the part in our code
which instantiates an array
we already know exactly how large the
array is going to be
either because we've populated it with
the elements needed
or given it a definitive final size
this means we also know exactly how much
space we need to reserve in memory
for that array combining these two
pieces of knowledge
means we can instantaneously figure out
the location of every single element
within the array
by simply taking the starting location
of the array in memory
and then adding to it the index of the
element that we're trying to find
so let's say our array contains three
elements each of them integers
and we want to know what the element at
the first index is
well we know that the array starts
storing data here
and we also know that every element
within the array is stored contiguously
together
in memory and so by taking the starting
location for the array in memory
and adding 1 to it we now know that
that's where the first index of our
array is going to be
and can return that stored value
appropriately
this is the main reason why array sizes
cannot be changed
all of the information within an array
must be stored in this one
place so that we're able to do this the
contiguous structure of an array
prevents you from adding space to it
after it's been initialized because it
literally can't without breaking up the
data
and adding in the space to store new
elements down the road
away from the initial array this would
make accessing elements
instantaneously not possible hopefully
now you can see why both
accessing an element within an array is
of one
as well as why array sizes are final
because not many other data structures
allow you to have
instantaneous accessing power meaning
arrays have a huge advantage on the
others in this metric
next up searching through an array is o
of n
this is because for the most part you
will be working with unsorted arrays
those being arrays which are not in
alphabetical numerical
or some sort of quantifiable order
meaning that to find an element within
the array
you may have to search through each
element before you can find it
this is known as a linear search and if
you want to know more about it
click the card in the top right corner
and it will take you to that section in
our introduction to programming series
a link will also be provided in the
description below
now while there are faster ways to
search through an array
those only work when the array is sorted
and so for a basic array
in worst case scenario searching through
it to find a particular element is going
to be o of
n now sure there are going to be cases
where the element you're searching for
is the first element in the array or
even somewhere in the middle
but remember that when working with big
o notation we always use the worst case
scenario
and in this case the worst case scenario
is that the item that you're searching
for
ends up being the last element within
the array
which for an array of size n would take
n operations to reach
finally inserting and deleting elements
from an array
both have a time complexity equation of
o of n
for inserting this is because adding an
element into the array requires you to
shift
every element that's after the index you
want to insert the value at
to the right one space for example
if you have an array of size five
currently filled with four numbers
and you want to insert the number one
into the array at index zero
you would first need to shift every
element to the right of the zeroth index
right one essentially freeing up the
space for the new integer
while also retaining all of the
information currently stored within the
array
then and only then can you actually
insert it
this requires you to traverse through
the whole array of size
n which is why the time complexity
equation is o of
n now sometimes you might not have to
shift the whole list
say in the case you had the same array
of numbers only this time the fourth
index was free
and you wanted to insert the number five
in that open spot
since you don't have to move everything
to the right one in order to make space
for this new element
does that make inserting into an array
have a time complexity equation of
o of 1 well no because again
when we talk about a function's time
complexity equation
we always refer to it in the worst case
scenario
the most amount of operations that we're
going to have to conduct
before we can insert an element into an
array is
n the size of the list making its time
complexity equation
o of n deleting an element from an array
follows mostly the same idea
you shift every element to the right of
the one you want to delete
down one index and essentially you have
deleted that element
again let's say we had an array of
numbers one through five
only this time we want to delete the
number one at the zeroth index
what we would do is set the zeroth index
to whatever is contained at the first
index
in this case the integer 2. and then
we simply repeat this process until we
get to the end of the array
finishing it off by setting the last
element in the array to be some null
value
this deletes the element from the array
by basically replacing
it with a value to the right and then
this process is repeated
until it frees up one space at the end
essentially we're just moving the entire
array down one
now worst case scenario we're going to
have to shift every element in the array
of size n
making deleting from an array also have
a time complexity equation
of o of n so there you have it
the four time complexity equations for
an array
accessing is of one and searching
inserting and deleting are all
ofn arrays are a really good data
structure for storing similar
contiguous data its ability to access
any item in constant time makes it
extremely useful for programs in which
you would like to be able to have
instant access to the information
contained within your data structure
it's also a lot more basic than some of
the other data structures that we'll end
up talking about
making it both easy to learn and
reducing the complexity of your code
now some disadvantages of the array are
the fact that the size of the array
cannot be changed once it's initialized
inserting and deleting from an array can
take quite a while if you're performing
the function on larger data sets
and if you have an array which is not
full of elements you're essentially
wasting memory space
until you fill that index location with
a piece of data
overall the array is a pretty reliable
data structure
it has some flaws as well as some
advantages
a program that you write could use the
array if need be
and it would work just fine but
sometimes you might want some extra
functionality
and that's where more advanced data
structures come into play
one of those more advanced data
structures is what's known as the
arraylist
the arraylist fundamentally can be
thought of as a growing array
we just finished talking about the array
and how one of its major flaws was the
fact that
once initialized an array size could not
be changed using conventional methods
well in contrast an arraylist size
expands as the programmer needs
if you take a look at the arraylist on
your screen now
full of four elements and you decide to
add one to it
it will simply expand its size to fit
five elements
as you can probably tell this is
extremely useful
which begs the question of why not just
always use arraylists
i mean in comparison the arraylist seems
to provide all the functionality of an
array
and then some well that's definitely a
valid question
and one we will get to later on in this
section but before we can do that
we need to cover the basics of an
arraylist including some of the
properties and methods associated with
it
alright let's hop in so as we've said
before
an arraylist is simply a resizable array
making them extremely similar in
structure
this is furthered by the fact that an
arraylist is actually backed by an array
in memory
meaning that behind the scenes of your
code the arraylist data structure uses
an array as its scaffolding system
for this series we need not go further
than that
but for us it just means that a lot of
the functionality will be the same now
this doesn't mean
everything is going to be the same which
you'll see later on
but it's still important to make note of
before we get too deep into things
the next thing i want to do before we
talk about functionality
is actually go over how we initialize an
arraylist
to do this again is going to vary based
on which language you're using
so shown on your screen now are two
different ways to do so
in java and c sharp you may notice again
that there is no python on the screen
and this is because in the base version
of python
arrays and arraylists are actually not
separate entities
they are frankenstein together into a
single data structure called lists
take some functionality from arrays and
some from array lists
it's a lot more complicated than that
but for this series that's all you're
going to need to know
as to why we are not including python in
this section
we discussed initializing python lists
in the previous section
so if you're interested you can go back
and look at that
now going back to arraylist
initializations another thing you may
notice is that it looks a little bit
awkward in the way that these statements
are structured
and that's mainly due to the fact that
the arraylist is actually its own
separate class
outside of the base version of these two
languages
now i'm not going to get into class
hierarchy and object oriented
programming right now
because that's a whole other topic with
big concepts and even bigger words
for right now this just means that to
create a new arraylist
we have to invoke the arraylist class
when defining it
which as you can see is done at the
beginning of both initializations
after that you can see that we give it a
name which is then set equal to
new arraylist with a set of parentheses
now in this parentheses you have a few
options you can either
enter in an integer which will then be
used to define a size for the arraylist
or you can just leave it blank leaving
the parentheses blank like that
will automatically define a preset size
of 10 for the arraylist
again just as a reminder this can be
dynamically increased as time goes on
if we add enough elements but it's just
meant as a base size
now you may be wondering if we can
actually populate the array with
elements when initializing it
as we could with arrays but arraylists
actually do not support this type of
declaration
moving on let's talk about functionality
now the arraylist can be thought of as
pretty much the evolved form
of an array it's a bit beefier has a
little bit more functionality
and is overall more powerful than an
array
that's certainly not to say that it's
better in every case
but for the most part the arraylist is
going to be thought of as the older
sibling amongst the two
this is attributed to the fact that it
belongs to the pre-built arraylist class
which we talked about earlier
the fact that the arraylist belongs to a
class means it's going to come with
pre-built functions that are already at
our disposal
from the moment we define and
instantiate an arraylist
more specifically the arraylist comes
with methods we can use to
access change add to or delete from it
easily
if you were using an array you would
have to program most if not all of these
methods by hand
and so having them pre-built into the
arraylist class
makes it especially useful you'll see
that this is the case with a lot of the
data structures down the road
where having a data structure belonging
to its own class cuts out a lot of
programming time
you have to spend making appropriate
methods for the functionality that you
might want
now the types of methods that you're
going to get will vary based on language
for example in java you'll have a
variety of methods to use
including ones to add elements to the
array list remove them from the array
list
clear the arraylist entirely return its
size etc etc
as well as tons of other more specific
functions
in another language though such as c
sharp
you'll have some of the same methods as
the java array list
but you might also have some methods
that the java version does not
and vice versa the c-sharp version
might not have some of the methods that
the java version does
the same is going to apply for any other
language you use which might implement
the arraylist data structure
because of the variability surrounding
the arraylist amongst languages
in this series we're simply going to be
covering six of the most common methods
that are both useful
and can be found in 99 of the arraylist
classes
these six methods are the add method the
remove method
the get and set methods the clear method
and the two array method this may look
like a lot
but remember all of these are
pre-programmed for you
and so you don't have to make them all
by hand all you have to do is call them
on a pre-made array list and you're set
to go
speaking of pre-made array lists before
we dive into each of these functions and
how they work
let's first create an example arraylist
we can use to manipulate and show how
they work
let's call it examplealist and give it a
size of 4 so that it's not preset to 10
and we're set to go now the add method
actually comes in two different types
one which takes in only an object to add
to the end of the array list
and one which takes in both an object to
add to the arraylist
as well as an index value representing
the index to insert the object at
let's start with the simpler of the two
one which simply takes in an object
this method is for more basic cases
where you don't care about
where in the arraylist the object you
wish to add is going to end up
it will simply append the object you
pass in as an
argument to the end of the arraylist
so let's take our example arraylist and
run the add method
on an integer of 2. now
normally arraylists only hold objects
not primitive types like the integer 2
that we're trying to pass in
however the computer will automatically
convert our primitive integer
into an integer object with a value of 2
so that we can still add it easily
this is known as autoboxing and is going
to be used throughout the rest of the
series to modify data structures with
primitive types
so i just thought i'd mention it now so
that you're not confused later on
okay so when we run our code since the
arraylist is empty
and we ran the add method which doesn't
care about location
it's going to add the integer 2 at the
first index
index 0. now if we run another add
method
and this time pass in the integer 5 as
an argument
since the zero with index is already
taken it will be slotted in as the first
available
open index that being the first index
so as you can see it's pretty simple it
takes in an object and will put it at
the first
open location available moving on to the
second type of add method
one which takes in an object to add to
the arraylist as well as an index to
place it at
this one works very similarly to the
previous only
make sure that the object that you're
adding is appended at the index provided
again let's say now we want to add the
number one to our example arraylist
but we want to make sure it's placed in
numerical order
in this case at the zero with index what
we would do is call the add method
providing the integer 1 as an argument
in addition to the index 0 we want to
add to the array list
once the code has run the array list
will automatically shift
our integers 2 and 5 to the right one
in order to make space for the integer
1.
this works for any index contained
within the bounds of the array list
so if we wanted to do it again only this
time insert the number 3
at the second index so that the list
remains in numerical order
we'd call examplealist.add and then in
the parentheses
pass in the integer 3 and the index
location 2.
after the code has run you'll see that
we have added the integer
into our arraylist now it's important to
note that because there are two integers
being passed in as arguments
you must know which one your computer is
treating as the integer
and which one the computer is treating
as the index location
mixing these up could cause the computer
to try and insert the attempted index
location
at a different location than the one you
were attempting to insert at
so just be careful and knowledgeable as
to the order your methods
arguments are in now the next method
that comes pre-packaged in the arraylist
class
is the remove method and this one also
comes with two different types
the first takes in an integer as an
argument and
just as the name suggests will remove
the object
if there is one at the index location
provided
and return it back to the user the
second
takes in an object and will simply
remove the first instance of that
object within the arraylist if present
and will then return true or false
whether an object was removed
so if we wanted to remove the number 5
from our arraylist
we would have two different options we
could call examplealist.remove
and inside the parentheses place the
index of the value we want to remove
in this case 3 and the program will
remove the object at index 3.
the other option would be to run another
remove method
only this time pass in an integer object
of 5.
it has to be an integer object because
if we were to just use
5 the computer would try to remove the
fifth index of the arraylist which
doesn't even exist
by creating an integer object we can
ensure that when the code runs
the computer knows that we want to
remove the first instance of the number
5 in our arraylist
and running this will return true and
remove the integer from our list
now if there is no integer 5 in the
arraylist the remove method will simply
return
false now i quite like the number 5 so
i'm actually not going to permanently
remove it from the arraylist
just yet up next is the get method
now the get method is pretty much the
same as referencing an index for an
array
it takes in an index location and will
return back to you the value at that
location
so examplealist.get with an argument of
0 would return 1
examplealist.get with an argument of 2
would return
3 and so on
the next method is the set method which
is how we replace elements within an
arraylist
much like the name implies it takes in
an index
and an object as arguments and will set
the index
location of the index you passed in to
the object you also
passed in so if we wanted to set the
number 5 in our arraylist to be
4 instead so that it matches nicely with
the other integers
what we would do is call
examplealist.set
and within the parentheses pass in the
index location of the element we want to
set
in this case 3 and then also the object
we want to replace at that index
in this case the integer 4. this
method call will override the element at
position 3
to be 4 instead of 5. now you should be
really careful when you're using this
method
because you don't want to accidentally
override an important element within the
array list
next up is the clear method for when you
simply just
hate your arraylist this is perhaps the
simplest of them all
it does not take in any arguments and
will simply clear the arraylist deleting
every element entirely calling
examplealist.clear
on our arraylist would delete all the
objects within it
but i don't really want to do that right
now especially with one more method to
go
so for the sake of this series let's
just keep the arraylist filled with the
values that it currently has
the final method that we'll be covering
in this section is a little bit
different from the rest
and that's the to array method which is
used to convert an arraylist to an array
i thought i would include this one
because it's really useful for combining
the strengths and weaknesses of arrays
and arraylists
the twoarray method takes in no
arguments
and will simply convert the array list
into an array
now for this to work of course you need
to set it to be equal to the creation of
a new array
like shown on your screen now but if it
is done correctly
you'll end up with a brand new array
which contains all of the contents that
used to be in the old array list
you may notice though that instead of an
array of integers
it's actually an array of objects this
mostly has to do with
that object oriented programming stuff
we talked about in the beginning
but for now it won't make too much of a
difference we can still treat it as a
regular array
printing out indexes to the console
placing elements within it
typical array functionality the only
thing that changes
is that it now contains integer objects
instead of primitive integer types
so there they are the six major
functions that come with any given
version of the arraylist class
having these at your disposal will
account for much of the functionality
you might use an arraylist for
making them extremely valuable to know
let's now move on to the arraylist as a
data structure
again we're going to be looking at its
four time complexity equations for
accessing
searching inserting and deleting now if
you remember back to the beginning of
this segment
we mentioned that the arraylist is
backed by an array in memory
and this means just like the array it
too will have o of one accessing power
essentially this means that when we use
our get method
which takes in an index location it will
return to us the value at the index
provided in instantaneous time
now you might be wondering how is this
possible since the data stored within an
array list is certainly not contiguous
what this is actually due to a really
interesting reason so interesting that
before scripting the series
i actually had no idea was the case so
because it is my series i'm going to
take a moment to talk about it
so if we pull up our example arraylist
in memory you
can see that it looks a little bit
different let's break down what's going
on
instead of storing the actual objects
which are contained within itself
an arraylist actually stores references
or pointers
to the locations of those objects in
memory
so the zeroth index based on the
arraylist
is stored at the 87th location in memory
which is currently storing the integer
1.
checking back to our example arraylist
you'll remember that that
is indeed what was stored at the zeroth
index of the example arraylist
and this goes for every element within
the arraylist
the first is stored at the 91st memory
location
the second at the 100th and so on
so as you can see while the actual data
is not stored contiguously
the references to that data data are
so when we run our get command all it
has to do is return the value that's
stored
at whatever the index location points
towards
it's a bit more complicated than that
especially the way that these references
get stored
but that covers the gist of it this is
the reason our arraylist can have
instantaneous accessing power
without having the data stored
contiguously
all right tangent over let's get back to
big-o notation time complexity equations
for the array list so we know
accessing is going to be o of 1 and
searching is going to be o of
n this is for the same reason that
arrays were o
n if we want to find out if an object is
contained within our array list
and that object is at the last index of
the arraylist
we're going to have to search through
each and every element within it
of size n to make sure because remember
we always go based on the worst case
scenario
now inserting into the arraylist is
going to be o of n
because worst case scenario if we are
inserting an element at the beginning of
the arraylist
we need to shift every element after the
index we're inserting
to the right one just like we needed to
do for the array
this requires a number of operations
equal to the size of the array
making inserting o of n
deleting is o of n for the exact same
reason
if we want to delete the first element
within the array list
we would then have to shift every
element down one to save space
additionally if we want to delete an
object contained at the last index
we have to search through the whole list
to find it either way it will
be o of n all right so there are our
four time complexity equations
accessing is of one and searching for
inserting and deleting
are all o of n if that sounds kind of
familiar
that's because these are the same as the
arrays time complexity equations
see i told you they were similar now
this does bring back up the question we
posed at the beginning of the episode
why even use an array in the first place
in comparison to the arraylist the array
just does not seem as useful
well let's get into that by sizing these
two data structures against each other
monoi mono
let's compare an array is a collection
with a fixed size
meaning it cannot be changed whereas an
array list has a dynamic size which can
be updated to fit the needs of the
programmer
arrays can store all types of data
meaning both primitives and advanced
types
whereas array lists can only store
objects not primitives
now this problem is mostly solved
through the autoboxing situation i
talked about previously
but the fact still stands moving on
an array is built into most languages
meaning it doesn't have any methods
pre-made for you to interact or modify
it
whereas an array list is its own class
meaning it comes with useful methods to
help you utilize it
finally an array is very primitive in
nature and doesn't require a lot of
memory to store or use
whereas an array list is again a class
media requires more space and time to
use than an array will
hopefully now you can see that while the
arraylist is more powerful
it still does have some drawbacks which
make using an array sometimes more
appropriate
in general you want to use arrays for
smaller tasks where you might not be
interacting or changing the data that
often and array lists for more
interactive programs where you'll be
modifying the data quite a bit
so that's the array list as a review it
is a dynamically increasing array which
comes with a slew of methods to help
work it
as the arraylist is a hefty topic in
computer science
if you feel i didn't do a good enough
job explaining some of the concepts in
the video
the sources used to write the script for
this video will be linked in the
description below
but if not let's move on to our next
data structure
the next data structure we'll be talking
about is the stack
now at this point in the video we'll be
diverging from what are known as
random access data structures ie arrays
and array lists
and diving into sequential access data
structures
what's the difference well if you
remember back to our discussion on
arrays and array lists
we were able to access any element
within the data structure by calling
upon its index location
this would then result in the computer
instantaneously returning the value at
that location
each element was independent of the one
before or after it
meaning obtaining a certain element did
not rely on any of the others contained
within the data structure
that basically describes the gist of a
random access data structure
one where each element can be accessed
directly and in constant time
a common non-computer science example of
a random access
would be a book getting the information
contained on a certain page
doesn't depend on all the other pages
within that book
and getting an element contained within
a random access data structure
doesn't depend on all the other elements
contained within that data structure
in contrast elements in a sequential
access data structure
can only be accessed in a particular
order
each element within the data structure
is dependent on the others
and may only be obtainable through those
other elements
most of the time this means that
accessing a certain element won't be
instantaneous
a common non-computer science example of
sequential access
would be a tape measure to get to the
measurement of 72 inches
you would first have to go through
inches 1 through 71.
there's no way to just instantly get to
72 inches
without first breaking every law of
thermodynamics and probably the space
time continuum
these are also sometimes called limited
access data structures
because unlike random access the data is
limited by having to obtain it through a
certain way
so there you have it random access data
structures which allow instantaneous
accessing power
and independent elements such as the
array and array list
and then you have sequential access data
structures which only allow
accessing through a particular order
with dependent elements
through the next few segments we'll be
covering a few of the popular sequential
access data structures
such as stacks cues linked lists and so
on
beginning of course with the stack we've
already danced around the subject long
enough so let's finally talk about what
a stack
actually is now the stack
by definition is a sequential access
data structure
in which we add elements and remove
elements according to the lifo principle
the lifo principle which stands for last
in
first out means that whichever element
we added to the stack
last will be the first one we retrieve
hence
last in first out think of this as a
stack of books
each time you add another book to the
top you do so by stacking it on top of
the others
then if we want to get a book in the
middle of that stack we would first have
to take off all the books on top of it
we can't just grab that book from the
stack and expect the entire thing not to
fall in on itself like some sort of
literaturistic jenga
the same goes for the stack as a data
structure we add elements to the top of
the stack
and retrieve them by taking them off the
top of the stack
there's only one way in and one way out
for the data
we can't simply access or modify an
element within the stack all willy-nilly
like we were able to do with the array
and the array list
this might seem like a weakness limiting
the flow of data to one single point
but remember what i said during the
segment on time complexity
many of these data structures have a
built-in functionality which gives them
an edge over the others
and the stack with its lifo property is
a prime example of that
next up let's talk about some of the
methods commonly associated with the
stack
now the stack class will always come
with two methods pre-built into its
class
those being push and pop these are the
fundamental methods which we use to
interact and modify the stack
making them extremely important to
comprehend
in addition to those two i'm also going
to cover two more methods
peak and contains which are both useful
and can be found in the stack class
associated with most programming
languages
now just like we had an example array
list let's also create an example stack
to help us show off these methods and
just like that
we're ready to roll now push is a method
which
pushes an object onto the top of the
stack
all it takes in as an argument is an
object to add to the stack
and will return no value when we do this
that object becomes the forefront of the
stack and its size is dynamically
increased by one
let's start running some push commands
on a variety of different strings
you'll see that the stack slowly gets
built now
channel this to subscribe
a series of completely random words
seamlessly pushed onto the stack
as you can see we're only adding
information to one spot
the top there's no insert method where
we can just
jam a string into the middle of the
stack
moving on the pop method is used to
remove an element from the top of the
stack
it does not take in any arguments and
will return the element that has popped
off the stack
back to the user once a pop method has
run
the element that was at the top of the
stack is removed and returned back to
the programmer
and the element which was second from
the top becomes the new top of the stack
and so on our example stack if we popped
off each element
you'd see that each time one of these
completely random strings
is taken from the stack and returned
back to the user
until we are left with a sad empty stack
with no shameless promotion let's add
the strings back
obviously just for the sake of the next
two methods that we need to cover
and not for continuing the free
advertising
so push and pop are how we add and
remove the data within our stack
so they're fundamentally the backbone of
the data structure
the next two i want to talk about peak
and contains
are more so used to interact with the
data inside the stack
without actually changing it not as
useful for modifying data
but still extremely important the first
of these is the peak method
the peak method allows you to get the
value at the top of the list
without actually removing it we talked
about before that the only way to access
elements in a stack was through the top
and this method is simply a way to look
at what the top value is
without having to pop it off it takes in
no arguments and will just return back
the contents of the top element
in our case if we ran it on our example
stack subscribe would be returned back
to the user
now if we popped off the top element and
ran it again
2 would be returned instead you get the
idea
again let's push subscribe back on the
top for
educational purposes
now the final method i'll be covering is
the contains method
this one is used for searching
throughout the stack it takes in an
object as an argument
and will return a boolean of whether or
not that item is contained within the
stack
essentially this method allows us to
search through the stack
without popping off every element until
we find the one we're looking for as the
contains method does not modify the
stack in any way
so for example examplestack.contains
with an argument of subscribe would
return true
example.contains with an argument of
this would also return true
but example.contains with an argument of
hello
would return false so there they are
four common stack functions which are
going to be vital
if you ever want to construct a stack
based program
moving on to time complexity for
accessing the stack has a time
complexity equation of
o of n this is because in order for us
to reach a certain element within the
stack
we first have to pop off every element
that's above it
think of it like this if we had a stack
of stones
and needed to get to the bottom one we'd
first have to take off
every stone on top of it so worst case
scenario
if the element we want is at the bottom
of the stack
we first have to pop off every element
above it
this would require a number of
operations equal to the size of the
stack
making the time complexity equation o of
n
this is one of the major drawbacks to
using stacks
with arrays and array lists we could
easily access any element within the
data structure
instantaneously and with a stack that's
just not possible
because of the way that it's structured
searching is going to be of n for the
exact same reason
worst case scenario if we're searching
for an element that's at the bottom of
the stack
we have to go through the whole thing
just to find it
now inserting and deleting make up for
this by having time complexity equations
of o of one
this essentially boils down to the fact
that using our push and pop methods
really only requires one operation since
the data only flows
in and out of a single point inserting
or removing an object from that point
can be done immediately
for the push method we simply add it to
the top of the stack
and for the pop method we just take it
off from the top it's not rocket science
actually it's computer science but
that's besides the point
there's no need to rearrange data or
move elements around like there was for
the array and array list because we
don't have to
the data that we're modifying is right
there on top
so there you go the time complexity
equations for the stack
now you might be wondering if there are
even uses for a first in first out data
structure
because it seems kind of out there i
mean limiting your
data to a single entry point but you
would actually be mistaken
stacks are used everywhere both in the
actual writing of other code
as well as in real world situations
in fact one of the most fundamental
processes of computer science
uses stacks as a way of keeping track of
active functions or subroutines
of course i'm talking about recursion
now i won't get into recursion too much
here
but basically it's the process of
functions repeatedly calling themselves
when the function calls itself that call
is added to a stack of processes
and when that stack finally reaches
what's known as a base case
the functions are all then popped off
one by one
it goes much much deeper than that but
we don't have time for a full-blown
lesson on recursion right now
if you want that you can click the card
in the top right corner of your screen
or the link in the description below
which will both take you to that part in
our introduction to programming series
where we cover it
either way stacks are the backbone for
recursion and recursion is the backbone
for a plethora of computer science
related functionality
such as traversing data structures
keeping track of active subroutines in
code
and much much more some examples of
stack-based functions
outside of computer programming which
you use every day
include the undo redo button in word
processors
and the back paging on web engines
both use stacks similarly they
continually add
tasks you've completed to a stack either
web pages that you visited or words that
you've typed
and then when you press undo or the back
button in a web browser
all we have to do is pop off whatever
the last task was
off the stack and bam you're right back
to where you were a second ago
it's like magic but better in a way
as you can see the stack has a lot of
real world applications both on the
consumer side
and the client side you interact and use
stacks every day without even realizing
it
and will use stacks frequently as you
continue along your computer science
journey
and so by learning them you're opening
up a world of opportunities
that concludes our discussion on the
stack to review
it is a sequential access data structure
in which we use the lifo principle to
add and remove
elements from and again lifo stands for
last in first out up next we'll be
talking about an equally useful data
structure that functions very
differently than the stack
while also working very similarly and
that data structure is known as the
queue
so now that we've talked about the stack
a sequential access data structure which
follows the lifo principle
we need to cover the opposite in
computer science we obviously call a
queue
now by definition a queue is a
sequential access data structure which
follows the
fifo principle or first in first out
the stack and queue are very much a
dynamic duo when it comes to the world
of compsci
so you'll notice a lot of similarities
between the two and the way that they're
structured and how they work
today and in this segment we'll cover a
lot of the same topics as we did with
the stack
only for the queue now timestamps can be
found in the description
correlating to these topics but if
you're sticking around let's dive deeper
into what the queue
actually is well the queue like the
stack
is a sequential access data structure
meaning we can only access the
information contained within it
a certain way now if you remember back
to stacks
this certain way was through the lifo
methodology
or last in first out where the last
element pushed onto the stack would
always be the first one we popped off
similar to a stack of books that we add
to and remove from
now in contrast the queue follows what's
known as the
fifo methodology or first in first down
where the first element added to the
queue will always be the first one to be
removed
we can think of this as a line to your
favorite amusement park ride
mine as a kid was always the ring of
fire so let's just use that one as an
example
the first one to get there assuming we
don't have any cutters
will always be the first one who gets to
go on the ride
the later you show up the longer you
have to wait
this is the strategy used for cues when
adding and removing
objects the first element to be added
will also be the first one to be removed
another big difference between stacks
and cues is the location we add and
remove
elements from you might remember that
with the stack we added and removed
elements from one spot
the top with the cue however this is
different
we add elements to the back also known
as the tail
and we remove them from the front also
known as the head
this allows us to make sure that we 100
follow the fifo methodology
so there's your background information
on the queue sequential access
fifo methodology add elements to the
back and remove them from the front
got it good now let's dive head first
into how we can actually use a queue
by jumping into some common queue
methods
so just like the stack we're going to
have two methods used to add and remove
elements from the queue for the stack we
added elements with push
and removed them with pop in contrast
with the queue we add elements using onq
and remove them using dq in addition to
these two methods
we're also going to cover peak and
contains which if you watched the
previous segment
should look pretty familiar all right
let's start
oncue is the first method and the one we
use to add elements to the tail of the
queue
it takes in an object to put at the end
of the queue and simply adds that object
while also increasing the size of the
queue by 1.
let's pull up an example cue which you
can see currently has a size of 0
but say we call on cue on a completely
random string
let's say the string now that would be
added to the tail of the queue
and the size would increase by one now
because there's only one
element in the queue at this point the
string now is acting as both the head
and tail for us
we can of course fix that by on cueing a
few more completely random strings
if we add the string video the size goes
to 2
we can add this and it goes to 3. like
makes it 4
you get the idea and now we have a fully
functional cue
as you can see like is acting as the
tail being that it was the last string
added
and now is being treated as the head
which makes sense considering it was the
first
string to be added moving on dq
is the method we use to actually remove
elements from the head of our queue
it takes in no arguments and will return
the element that was removed from the
queue
back to the user so if we ran a dq
command
on our example queue you'd see that now
is both returned back to the user
and also removed from the queue
additionally the size of our queue
has been dynamically decreased by 1.
if we run it again video is returned and
removed from the queue
and the size goes down by one yet again
you get the idea
we can keep doing this for every element
in the queue until it's empty
but the next methods we're going to talk
about need some information to work with
so for now let's refill the queue back
to its original four
elements the next method that i'll
discuss
is peak now we've actually covered peak
just a few moments ago in our segment on
stacks
but if you forget or just didn't watch
that particular part
peak returns the object that's at the
forefront of our queue
it doesn't take in any arguments and
simply returns the foremost object of
the queue
without actually removing it the key
word there being without
this method allows you to look at the
head of the queue before you actually
dequeue it
there are a multitude of reasons that
you might want to do this
maybe to make sure that the element that
you're about to dequeue is the correct
one
or to check to see if an element you
need is still there
etc etc whatever the case is
we can use the peak method to fulfill
our needs
if we were to run it on our example
queue you'd see that the string
now is returned but if we dequeue the
first two elements and run it again
you'll see that the string this is
returned
pretty simple but extremely effective
again let's add video and now back into
the queue for our next and final method
that method of course being the contains
method
the name pretty much says it all the
contains method
will take in an object and will return a
boolean of whether or not the queue
contains that object
running it on our example queue with an
argument of q
would return false because as you can
tell there is no
queue string contained within our queue
however if we ran it on a string such as
video it would return true because as
you can see the string video
is indeed in the queue and there they
are all together now
on cue dq peak and contains
four methods which will help you utilize
a cue to its maximum efficiency
speaking of efficiency that takes us
perfectly into the time
complexity equations for the queue
now accessing an element within a queue
is going to be o of n
let's say you had a queue full of three
elements if you want the object at the
tail
you first have to dequeue every element
off the front
until the one you are looking for is the
head of the queue
then and only then can you actually get
the value contained
since this may require you to go through
the entire queue of size
n accessing is going to be o of n
remember now queues are sequential
access data structures and not random
access
meaning we can't just grab an object
from the middle of the queue
that's just not how things work
searching is going to be o
n for the exact same reason trying to
find an element contained at the tail of
a queue
requires you to iterate across the
entirety of that queue to check for it
so in that scenario we have to check
every element within that queue of size
n making the time complexity equation
o of n inserting two and deleting from a
q
are both going to be an instantaneous o
of 1.
this is because just like with the stack
we're only ever on queuing at a single
point
and we're only ever dequeuing at a
single point
this means that no matter how large the
size of the queue is
it will always take the same number of
operations for any magnitude
to either insert or remove an element
and there they are in all their glory
the time complexity equations for the
queue
you may notice that they're identical to
the stack which if you've been paying
attention
is the truth for most of the properties
about a queue
they are very much a yin and yang one in
the same type deal
differing slightly in terms of the
methodology you use to add and remove
objects from them you'll often see these
two data structures talked about
together
frequently just because of how similar
their functionality is
the final thing i want to cover on the
topic of cues are just some common uses
for them within
programming what are these things
actually used for
and the answer is quite honestly a lot
on your computer right now
cues are being used for what's known as
job scheduling
the process through which the computer
determines which tasks to complete for
the user and when
like opening up a web page or a computer
program
it's used many times in printers to keep
track of when multiple
printers try to print and determining
whose documents get printed first
heck if you're looking for real world
examples google even uses cues in their
new pixel phones to enable what's known
as zero shutter lag
in which they strategically use cues to
eliminate the time between when you take
a picture
and what the phone actually captures so
yeah in terms of functionality the queue
can be used in a variety of fields
so it's good now that you know what they
are and how to use them
this also concludes our discussion on
the queue to review
the eq is a sequential access data
structure
which follows the fifo principle or
first in
first out to add elements to the back
and remove elements from the front
up next we'll continue on the sequential
access data structures train
and talk about one of my personal
favorite data structures
next we'll be covering the linked list
and it's a good one so strap into your
seats
let's just jump into things by talking
about the elephant in the room
what exactly is a linked list well to
answer that
a linked list is a sequential access
linear data structure
in which every element is a separate
object called a node
each node has two parts the data and the
reference
also called the pointer which points to
the next node in the list
wow that is a pretty big sentence with a
lot of
ideas within it so let's break it down
part by part
the sequential access part of that
statement means that the information
contained within the linked list data
structure can only be obtained through a
certain methodology
we talked about this in our segment on
the stack if you remember
during that segment we compared them to
a tape measure
because similarly you can only get
measurements from a tape measure through
a specific method
the specific method for a linked list
will be covered a little bit later
but moving on the linear part of the
definition
simply means that the information or
data is organized in a linear fashion
in which elements are linked one after
the other
now when we state that every element is
a separate object called a node
this means that unlike an array or an
array list where every element is just
let's say a number each element in a
linked list will actually be an
object which can have multiple
attributes or variables
now i won't dive too far into object
oriented programming right now
if you want a good introduction to that
you can check out the link in the
description below
which will take you to our introduction
to object oriented programming lecture
for this series we essentially mean that
the objects or notes
stored within each element of our linked
list will hold two separate pieces of
information
these two pieces of information come
together to form the node
and these nodes are what make up our
linked list
more specifically those two pieces of
information are the actual
data or information stored within that
node
and the reference or pointer to the next
node in the linked list
the data is where our strings or
integers or boolean values are kept
the actual contents of our data
structure and the other piece to the
puzzle is the pointer
this reference or pointer points to
where the next node in the linked list
is stored in memory
this helps link all of the nodes in a
length list together
to form one long chain of information
kind of like a computer science conga
line
you should now be able to understand
what a linked list is
again it's a sequential access linear
data structure
in which every element is a separate
object called a
node in which each node contains both
data and a reference to the next node in
the linked list
this cumulatively creates a string of
nodes which we call the linked list
feel free to re-watch this explanation
if you are still confused because i know
it can get pretty hectic
pretty fast the next thing i want to do
in this section
is just visualize how one of these
linked lists is set up
that way you can actually see what i
mean when i say nodes and pointers
and everything else etc so every linked
list starts with what's known as the
head node of the list
this is just an arbitrary label which
represents a node containing some form
of data
and also a reference the next node in
the linked list
for now let's just store the integer 1
in our head node
now since this is the only node so far
in our linked list
the head node will simply point towards
a null value
which is just to say it's not pointing
anywhere
essentially it's pointing to nowhere and
just being used as a placeholder
until we actually give it something to
point towards
let's do that by adding another node to
the length list
and store the integer 2 inside of it
instantly you can see that now our head
node points to this second node instead
of a null value
you'll also notice that this new node
which i'll call the two node
points to a null reference value just
like the one node used to do
as it is now the last node in the linked
list
this is a pattern you'll notice as we
continue adding nodes
the last node in a linked list also
known as the tail
node will always point towards a null
value
this is our way of telling the computer
that we've reached the end of our linked
list
and that there are no more nodes to
traverse towards
anyways let's now create our third node
and inside store the integer 3.
this node now becomes the tail and
points towards a null value
and the second node that we created the
one that used to point towards a null
value
now points to this new node which
contains the integer 3.
essentially we're just adding a node to
the tail of a linked list
and then setting the references of the
previous node to point towards that new
node
and if you can understand that concept
you pretty much comprehend the gist of
how these nodes interact
the two main takeaways are that every
node has both information and a pointer
and the last node in a linked list
points towards a null value
that's pretty much the setup for a
linked list definitely more
abstract and fluid than say an array or
arraylist
but hopefully not too complicated
next up we're going to be discussing how
we add and remove these nodes from a
linked list
unfortunately for us adding and removing
elements from a linked list
isn't going to be as simple as it was
with the other data structures
such as the stack or the queue this has
to do with the simple fact that we
are actually able to insert and remove
elements easily
within a linked list at any location
with a stack or a queue we weren't
actually able to do this
because the data could only flow in and
out of a few specified points
this made it so we couldn't remove an
element from the middle of the stack
or jam an element in the center of a
queue the way that they're structured
just didn't allow for this
using linked lists however we can easily
remove elements from the middle or
jam elements in the center and so today
we'll be covering the different methods
used to do so
more specifically we'll be covering
three different ways to both
insert and remove nodes from a linked
list
adding to and removing a node from the
head the middle
and the tail of a linked list these are
all going to revolve around those
pointers we talked about at the
beginning of the episode
because whenever we change up a node in
a linked list
we also have to change its pointers and
that can get pretty complicated
pretty quickly luckily that's why i'm
here
i've set up a basic linked list on your
screen now with three nodes that we can
use to play around with
each node has a value of course
representing the data inside the node
and also a pointer which points it to
the next node
the green and red coloring on the nodes
with the integers 1
and 3 simply indicate which node is the
head node and which node is the tail
node
green means head node and red means it's
the tail node
now in an actual linked list these
pointers would be locations in memory
but for the purpose of this series we'll
be representing the pointers visually
perfect so let's cut the chit chat and
just jump right into it
the first method we're going to be
covering is adding and removing nodes
from the head of a linked list
lucky for us this is pretty simple to
add a new node to the head of a linked
list
literally all we have to do is make that
new node's pointer
point to whatever the current head node
of the linked list is
by doing this we simply take away the
title of head node from the current head
and bestow it upon this new node that
we're adding
it looks a little bit something like
this let's take a node with the integer
and add it to the head of the linked
list all we have to do to do this
is set its pointer to point towards the
current head node
now you'll see that none of the other
nodes have changed in the slightest
the only thing that has changed is that
this new node with integer 0
is the head node and it now points
towards the old head node
extremely simple and the best part is
that it works in reverse as well
removing a node from the head of a
linked list is just as simple
all we have to do is set the headnode's
pointer to some null value
once we do the headnode will get cut off
from the flow of information
essentially removed from the linked list
if we did this on our example linked
list
you'd see that once we set the zero
node's pointer to null
because it no longer points to the one
node and no node points towards
its location it has been cut off from
the rest of the nodes and exiled from
the linked list
the old head node regains its position
and it's as if this integer zero node
never even exists moving on the next
methods we're going to cover
are inserting and deleting a node from
the middle of the linked list
these two methods are definitely the
most difficult of the bunch and this is
because we need to insert the node
in such a way that the pointers get
readjusted accordingly
without losing any of the information
if we accidentally set the pointers
wrong or do things out of order
the data could get lost forever but
luckily
i'm here to teach you how to do it the
right way we'll start with adding a node
to the middle of a linked list
adding to the middle of a linked list is
a two-step process
we first make the pointer of the new
node point to the node
after the location we want to insert at
then we set the node before the location
we want to insert at
to point towards the new node so
if we wanted to insert a node with the
double value 1.5
after the node containing the integer 1
but before the node containing the
integer 2
what we would first do is set the new
node's pointer to point to the node
containing the integer 2.
then we would make the node containing
the integer 1
point towards our new node which
contains the double 1.5
by adjusting the pointers of the nodes
before and after the location we want to
insert at
we can strategically jam this node in
the correct place
without moving or modifying the entire
list
as you can see now we have a linked list
of length 4
where the link has not been broken and
is also still contiguous
removing a node from the middle of the
linked list is even simpler
all we have to do is make the pointer of
the node previous to the one we're
removing
to now point to the node after the one
we're removing
then if we set the pointer of the node
we want to remove
equal to a null value we again cut the
node off from the linked list
and it is removed simple as that so
following these steps if we now wanted
to delete our 1.5 node
we'd make the one node again point
towards the 2 node
instead of the 1.5 node then
if we delete the pointer of the 2 node
by setting it equal to null
it gets cut off from the flow of the
linked list
no changes are externally made to the
rest of the list
just one lonely node removed
the final type of insertion and deletion
we'll be covering is inserting to and
deleting from the end of a linked list
doing this simply requires you to modify
the tail node of the linked list
the one which currently points towards
some null value
for adding a node to the tail you simply
make the current tails pointer
which is currently set to null to point
towards the node you want to add
so if we wanted to add a node with the
integer 4
we would just make the three node point
towards this new node
then by setting the four node's tail to
point towards null
we've made this new 4 node the tail of
the length list
and the old tail node with integer 3 now
points to the new tail
removing the tail of a linked list is
just as simple
if we want to remove the tail we just
set the previous tail
to point towards a null value instead of
the current tail
this leaves the current tail node with
no connection to the linked list
isolating it from the pack doing this on
our list would look like making the 3
node point towards null
and now because no node now points to
our tail node
containing the integer 4 anymore it gets
cut off from the linked list and
essentially removed
making the old tail node the one
containing the integer 3
the current tail node once again
and so after a bit of pointer
readjustment hopefully now you can
understand the pseudo code
behind inserting and removing elements
from a linked list with ease
up next are the time complexity
equations for a linked list
now accessing an element within a linked
list is going to be o of n
this is because linked lists again are
sequential access data structures
this should be all too familiar if you
watch the sections on stacks and queues
but if not let's just use a simple
review
sequential axis data structures can only
be accessed through a particular way
meaning we can't get any element we want
instantaneously
resulting from this is the stipulation
that if we want to get a certain element
within a linked list we need to start at
the beginning of the list
and cycle through every node contained
within it before we can finally access
the one that we want
we do this by using the pointers as a
little map for the computer
first go to node 1 node 1's pointer
gives you the location of node 2 in
memory
and node 2's pointer will take you to
the memory location
which contains the node with the
information that you want
it's like a computer science treasure
map in a way
for a linked list of size n this means
you could have to traverse the entire
linked list before finding your
information
making its time complexity equation of n
searching is o n for the exact same
reason we
check a node and if it's not the one
that we want
we use that node's pointer to take us to
the next node and check that one
we do this for every node until we
either find the node containing the
value we want
or get to a node which points towards
null indicating that we've reached the
end of the linked list
and that the value that we're searching
for just isn't contained within that
particular linked list
inserting and deleting from a linked
list is a little bit complicated
since linked lists usually only store
the head and
sometimes the tail node's location in
memory permanently
if we want to insert or delete an
element at the beginning or
end of a linked list we can do so
instantaneously using the methodology we
talked about previously
however if we want to insert a node
within the linked list
things become a little bit more
complicated in order to insert a node
within the linked list we must first
traverse to the location we want to
insert at
this means following that treasure map
until we reach the insertion point
and then and only then can we actually
follow the instructions to insert or
delete a node
so depending on how and where you want
to insert or delete a node at
its time complexity equation will be
either o of n
or o of 1. a little confusing yes but
necessary dimension for when it
inevitably comes up
so in review accessing searching and
sometimes inserting and deleting are all
going to be of n
and other times inserting and deleting
will be instantaneous cool
now let's finish up by talking about
some real world applications of the
linked list
now something i haven't talked about
before but would be scolded by people in
the comments for not mentioning
is that linked lists can actually be
used in the backing of other data
structures
what do i mean by this well basically we
can use
linked lists to make stacks cues and
some other data structures we haven't
talked about
this is in the same vein as earlier when
i mentioned that the arraylist
uses the array as a backing support
system in memory
now this goes a little bit above an
introductory series but it's one of
if not the most important uses of a
linked list in computer science
so i thought i'd mention it here
basically
because of the way that it's structured
having a stack or cue use the nodal
methodology that we talked about during
this episode which comes with a linked
list
to be the back end of its structure
makes a lot of sense
if you're curious i'll have an article
linked below explaining this idea
in better detail i just thought it was a
little bit above the complexity for an
introductory course
now that's not to say linked lists can't
be useful in other ways
a cue on spotify for instance where each
song in the queue doesn't contain just
an integer or string
but an entire song with wave data a
title
a length etc then when the track is done
it automatically points to the next song
in the playlist
another example could be a photo viewing
software where
each node is an image and the pointers
simply point to the next photo in the
list
like i said the main functionality of a
linked list might be to back other data
structures
but it also has tons of uses in other
areas of expertise
in review a linked list is a sequential
access
linear data structure in which every
element is a separate object called a
node
containing two parts the data and the
reference pointer which points to the
next node that comes in the linked list
these pointers allow us to easily shift
around each node
adding or removing it without having to
move mass amounts of data
like we would have to do in the case of
an array or some other data structure
one thing i haven't mentioned yet about
linked lists is that this pointer system
does come with one big drawback
with a normal linked list we can only
ever go forward with our pointers
never backwards from the computer's eyes
once we follow a pointer to a certain
node's location in memory
there's no way to go back or undo to the
previous one
much like a shark we can and only will
ever go forward
this problem is fixed however through
the use of a data structure
known as the doubly linked list which
coincidentally is the subject of the
next segment in this video
small world all jokes aside next up
we're going to be covering the doubly
linked list
so strap into your seats a doubly linked
list is
almost exactly the same as a linked list
that is to say
it's a sequential access data structure
which stores data in the form of nodes
except with doubly linked lists there's
one small difference
with the doubly linked list we're able
to traverse both forwards to the next
node in the list
and backwards to the previous node in
our list again using pointers
how well let me explain with regular
linked lists
each element was a node composed of both
a data section
and then a pointer which would take you
to the memory location of the next node
in the list
using this we were able to traverse a
linked list easily
to search for information access data
within a linked list
or add and remove nodes from within the
list with ease
a doubly linked list simply builds upon
this by also having a pointer which
points to the previous node's location
in memory
it's an undo button of sorts which
allows you to fluidly go through the
linked list in either direction
instead of just limiting yourself to
going one direction
this is great since it allows us to jump
around the linked list and have a lot
more flexibility when it comes to
modifying information
now because this can get pretty
confusing very quickly i want to do a
visualization
before that though let's use some lingo
to help consolidate the terminology that
i'll be using
when i refer to a node's next i'm
referring to that particular node's
pointer
which points to the next object in the
list whether that be another node or
null value
similarly when i refer to a node's
previous
abbreviated to prev on the visuals i'm
talking about its pointer which points
to the previous object in the linked
list
again either another node or null value
doing this just helps keep things a
little bit more simple because
as you'll see having both a previous and
a next pointer
makes things a little bit more
complicated
now on to what these doubly linked lists
actually look like
just like with a regular linked list
every doubly linked list is going to
start with a head node
since it's the first node in the list
both its previous pointer
and its next pointer will point towards
a null value
this is of course because it can't point
to information which isn't there
we can fix this though by adding another
node
once we do you can see that a few things
have changed
the headnode's next pointer now points
towards this new node instead of null
the new node's previous pointer now
points to the head node
and the new node's next pointer now
points towards a null value
as you can see it's a little bit more
complicated than adding a node to a
regular linked list in which we only had
to worry about one set of pointers
as opposed to two but still manageable
let's add one more node for
demonstration purposes and you'll see
the same thing happens again
the second node now points to this new
third node and this third node gets
initialized with a pointer which points
both to the previous second node
and also forward to some null value
you can see that with any two nodes the
next pointer of the first
and the previous pointer of the second
come together to form
sort of a cyclical connection which ties
the two nodes together
then at the head and tail of the list
there's a connection which ties them
both towards some null value
most of this should be common sense but
it's still good to go over
doubly linked lists are a little scary
at first but once you break them down
you realize that they're just an evolved
form of linked lists
up next we're going to be talking about
adding and removing nodes from a doubly
linked list
again using the three different methods
that we talked about in the previous
segment
adding and removing from the head the
middle and the tail
i've also set up a basic doubly linked
list with three nodes containing three
strings to help us out with this next
segment
finally just like the last segment the
green on top of a node signifies that
it's the head node
and the red signifies it's the tail node
all right with all that being said let's
get into it
now adding to the head of a doubly
linked list is quite simple
the first step is to take our new node
that we want to insert
and set its previous to null second we
set the new nodes next
to point towards the current head node
of the linked list
then all we do is set the current heads
previous to point towards this new node
instead of a null value
and we're set to go doing this
rearranges the pointers in such a way
that the new node we want to add
becomes the head of the doubly linked
list pretty simple
so if we wanted a new node with the
string abe to be the head of our doubly
linked list
we would just follow the steps first we
set the abe nodes next
to point towards the atom node then we
set its
previous to point towards a null value
and finally
by setting the atom nodes previous to
point towards the abe node
we have successfully added that node to
the head of the list
making it the head node
removing a node from the head is even
simpler
we first set the head nodes next to
point towards a null value
and then by setting the second node's
previous to also point towards a null
value
we can easily remove the head node from
the list
this is how it would look in our example
we'd first set the abe nodes next to
null
then we would set the atom nodes
previous to also be null
and then we're done now because the abe
node doesn't have anything to point
towards
nor does it have anything pointing
towards it it will be deleted from the
list
the atom node will regain its position
as the head node
and the program will carry on
up next is inserting and deleting from
the middle of a doubly linked list
this is where things get really tricky
so make sure you're paying attention
to insert a node into the middle of a
doubly linked list
we follow a three-step process the first
step is to take the node we want to add
and set its previous to point towards
the node previous to the position we
want to insert at
then we take that same node the one we
want to add
and set its next pointer to point
towards the node after the position we
want to insert at
finally we set the next on the node at
the position before the one we're
inserting
and the previous on the node after the
position we're inserting
to both point towards this new node
that is a lot of words some of which
might not even make sense to you
so let's open up the space on our screen
real quick and do an example with our
list
let's take a new node with the string
chris and add it between the atom node
and the bend node by simply following
our steps
first we want to set the new nodes
previous to point towards the node
previous to the position we want to
insert at
this means setting the chris nodes
previous to point towards the atom node
simple enough second we set the new
nodes
next to point towards the node after the
position we want to insert at
this entails setting the chris nodes
next to point towards ben
so far so good then the last step is to
set the node on the next before we're
inserting
and the previous on the node after we're
inserting to both point towards this new
node
so in this case the atom nodes next and
the bend nodes previous
both get set to the new chris node this
completes the addition
into the list obviously this is a little
bit more complicated than inserting or
deleting from the head
but as you can see we've now inserted
this new node into its rightful place
it may be hard to see since the pointers
are a little bit messy
but the flow of the list has remained
constant without any breaks in the
pointers
which is the most important part
removing a node from the middle of a
doubly linked list is also a three-step
process
first we set the node before the one we
want to remove
next to point towards the node after the
one we want to remove
then we set the node after the one we
want to remove
previous to point towards the node
before the one we want to remove
the final step is to set both pointers
of the node we want to remove
to point towards a null value again a
little complicated so let's take it to
our example list
and try it out let's delete the chris
note just for the sake of keeping things
consistent
following the steps that we've laid out
we would first set the next of the node
before the one we want to remove
to point towards the node after the one
we want to remove
so in this case we set the atom nodes
next to point towards the bend node
essentially skipping over the chris node
then
we set the previous of the node after
the one we want to remove
to point towards the node before the one
we want to remove
so we set the bend node to point towards
the atom node
again skipping over the chris node
finally we have to set the chris node's
pointers to point towards null values
now that we've done this because no
nodes point towards it
and it doesn't point towards any nodes
the chris node gets deleted from the
doubly linked list
the list is back to its original form
with no breaks or errors
adding a node to the tail of a doubly
linked list is also a three-step process
step one entails setting the next
pointer of the current tail
to point towards the new node we want to
become the tail
step 2 is setting the previous of the
new node that we're adding
to point towards the current tail of the
list
and step 3 is making the new nodes next
point towards a null
value again let's do an example where we
add a new node containing the string
ethen to the tail of the doubly linked
list
following our steps we first set the
next pointer of the current tail
the karl node to point towards the ether
node
then we make the ethan nodes previous
point towards carl
and it's next to point towards a null
value and we're all set
ethan has been successfully added as the
new tail of the list in three quick and
easy steps
removing from the tail of the list is
even easier and only requires two steps
we first set the tail nodes previous to
point towards null
and then we set the second to last nodes
next to also point towards null
on our example list it looks like this
we first set the ether nodes previous to
point towards null
then we set the coral nodes next to also
this isolates any pointers going to or
from the ether node and deletes it from
the list
making the coral node the tail once
again
adding and removing information from a
doubly linked list might sound like a
hassle
but remember we only have to use this
pseudo code to program these functions
once in whatever language we're
implementing them in
and then we're able to reuse them an
infinite amount of times
now for time complexity equations since
the doubly linked list is really just
an extension of the linked list its time
complexity equations are going to be
exactly the same as they were for the
linked list and for the exact same
reasons
o of n for all four cases and sometimes
o of one for both inserting and deleting
if you didn't watch the linked list
segment and are wondering how we arrived
at these equations
you can check the description for a time
stamp which will take you to the
discussion we had on linked list time
complexities
finally in terms of doubly linked lists
i just want to talk about some of the
uses for a doubly linked list
because there are a ton the back and
forth functionality of a doubly linked
list lends itself to be
implemented in a lot of stack like
functionality i.e
cases where you want to go back and
forth between information that you're
storing for the user
some examples of this could be the
browser caches which allow you to go
back and forth between web pages
the undo redo functionality in many
programs
applications which allow you to utilize
an open recent functionality
the list goes on and on basically any
case in which you need to store a list
of objects with multiple attributes
a doubly linked list is going to be a
safe bet to get it done
linked lists and their evolved form in
the doubly linked list
are a great way to store information
because of the adaptability of the nodal
structure
since we're not working with raw
information like primitive types
and we're storing all information inside
of a shell
it makes it a lot easier to move the
information around
this combined with the pointer system
allows for non-contiguous but still fast
operating speed making these two data
structures a staple in computer science
up next we'll be covering dictionaries
and with that a little mini lesson on
hash tables
this is the last of what i refer to as
the intermediate data structures at the
beginning
of the lecture and is honestly
personally one of my favorites
so let's not wait any longer and just
jump into things
before we get too far though we should
probably clarify that when we say
dictionary we're not referencing that
thick book you probably
have lying around your house and haven't
used in years
actually dictionaries are one of the
most abstract data structures which
exist in computer science
and can be used for a variety of
purposes another thing i'll clarify
really quickly
is that dictionaries are also sometimes
called both maps
and associative arrays by the computer
science community
this more so has to do with language
specifics and preferences
and not any functional differences since
all of them work in almost identical
ways
but for this series we're going to be
referring to them as dictionaries
just to keep things simple and organized
now a dictionary in computer science by
definition
is an abstract data structure which
stores data in the form of
key value pairs this means we have two
main parts to each dictionary element
the key and the value each value within
a dictionary has a special key
associated with it
and together they create a pair which is
then stored in the dictionary data
structure
as an element think of a key value pair
like a social security number
each social security number is a key
which is then paired with a value
that value being an individual person
these social security number key value
pairs then come together to form a
dictionary of every human being living
in the united states
this is very different from many of the
data structures we've talked about
previously
because we index dictionaries using
these keys instead of a numerical index
for example with an array we would index
each element within the data structure
according to a numerical value which
started at 0
and ran the length of the array with a
dictionary however
we index each element by using its key
instead of some arbitrary integer
and obtain information through that
index instead
so what exactly are these key value
pairs going to look like
well they can be just about anything the
keys in a key value pair
can be any primitive data type that you
can think of
we can have a dictionary which has
integers as the keys
one with strings as the keys one with
doubles as the keys
there's really a lot of flexibility as
for the values
well we have even more flexibility with
those
we can have keys in our dictionary
correspond to pretty much anything
strings sure booleans of course
another dictionary with its own set of
key value pairs
you can even do that too this allows us
to have tons of combinations in the way
that we store our data
making dictionaries extremely powerful
as powerful as they are though there are
two extremely important restrictions
that we have to cover when it comes to
dictionary and they are as follows
every key can only appear once within
the dictionary
and each key can only have one value
let's start with the first one each key
has to be unique and cannot be
replicated duplicated cloned copied or
anything else that would cause there to
be two keys of the same value in a
dictionary
think of it like this when you create a
key value pair
the computer creates a little locked box
in memory to store the value
then the computer spends days and weeks
creating a customized
handcrafted one-of-a-kind key that
corresponds directly to that locked box
this key cannot be replicated in the
slightest and that's the same mindset
you should use when working with
dictionaries
no two keys can be the same
if you were to try and make a dictionary
with two similar keys
you would be thrown in error by the
computer
the second stipulation is that each key
can only have
one value think back to our custom key
example
it wouldn't make sense for this one of a
kind key to be able to open multiple
boxes
the same is true for our keys in
computer science
they can only correspond to one value
now one rule that we don't have to
follow is that there can be duplicates
of values within a dictionary
meaning we can have two separate keys
both point towards equivalent values
as long as the keys are different the
computer does not care
all right now that we know what
dictionaries are and how they work
let's jump into the time complexity
equations for a dictionary
or at least try to let me explain
now for a dictionary the time complexity
equations are a little bit funky
previously we talked about linked lists
and how they are sometimes used as the
backing of other data structures in
memory
for example a stack might implement the
linked list structure
as its way of storing information well
the most common way to initialize a
dictionary
is to implement it with what's known as
a hash table
hash tables are a little more advanced
than the content i wanted to cover in
this series
but they are a huge part of dictionaries
especially when it comes to time
complexity
so we're going to give a little mini
lesson on them today
doing this will help you better
understand the time complexity equations
for a dictionary
as well as give you some background on
advanced data structures
alright let's begin with a little
thought experiment
imagine this scenario for a second say
we have a dictionary which contains a
few key value pairs like shown on your
screen now
let's just assume that to store all this
information in the computer's memory
we'd use an array like how it is shown
on your screen now
with the position that a cell is in the
table also corresponds to the key
and the key value pair stored in our
dictionary
so the zeroth cell would contain a key
with the integer 0
which leads to a value the fourth cell
would contain a key with the integer 4
which leads to another value and so on
any cell which we don't have a key for
is empty or what the computer scientists
refer to
as nil why does this not work
why can't we just use an array like this
to back our dictionary in memory
since it looks like actions such as
accessing and searching would run in
constant time
since all the keys correspond to their
table values in memory
all we'd have to do to get a value is
simply reference the key at the index
we're looking for
well this actually isn't the case
because it's based upon the simple
assumption that the size of the array
is not too large sure this might work
great for this dictionary where we have
10 or so elements but let's say instead
of 10 elements
evenly spaced out we want to have one
which has 10 values which are
sporadically placed from 1 to a billion
we want to keep the keys as being in the
same index position as their values
so we can know exactly where they are
and reference them easily but by my
count that is 999 million
999 990 nil values
just taking up space in memory and that
is not good whatsoever
there's got to be a better way to do
things right
well this is where our hash tables come
in hash tables are fundamentally a way
to store this information in such a way
that we're able to cut down the amount
of nil values
while also allowing for the information
to be stored in such a way
that it is easily accessible basically
by using a hash table we'd be able to
store these 10 keys in our dictionary
which range from 1 to a billion in a
table with only 10 elements
while also being able to keep constant
time
how is this possible well through the
use of a trick
programmers use known as hash functions
a hash function will take all the keys
for a given dictionary
and strategically map them to certain
index locations in an array
so that they can eventually be retrieved
easily
essentially by giving a hash function
both a key
and a table it can determine what index
location to store that
key at for easier retrieval later
these hash functions can be pretty much
anything which takes in a value and
returns an index location
the goal of a good hashing function is
to take in a key
whatever that may be and reliably place
it somewhere in the table so that it can
be accessed later by the computer
so with that being said let's just jump
into an example
because i know a lot of you might be
confused
let's say we have our dictionary which
contains keys in the form of integers
from one to a million by a factor of ten
so the keys are one ten one hundred
one thousand ten thousand a hundred
thousand and so on
a good hash function for this data set
would be to take the key
divide it by itself and then multiply
the result by the number of digits in
the key
minus one so to find out where to store
the value corresponding to the one
million key
we would take a million divide it by
itself which
yields one and then multiply that by the
number of digits in that integer
minus one in this case seven minus one
or six this means we'd store the 1
million key
at index location 6. if we do this for
every key in the dictionary
we can see that each key in the key
value pair is stored at some index from
0 to 9.
we've consolidated the 10 keys from one
to a billion
into 10 index slots instead of a billion
a pretty good improvement in my opinion
you might think this is a little over
complicated for storing 10 elements
but remember sometimes we might be
working with thousands of keys at a time
ranging in the billions or even strings
as keys which is
a whole other story now the best part
about these hash functions
let's say that we now want to get the
value which is paired with the one
million key
all we need to do is put 1 million back
into our hash function
and it'll tell us where the value tied
to that key is stored at within the
table
in this case at the sixth index doing
this allows us to pretty much
instantaneously find where any key value
pair is stored at within the table
all of this information may be pretty
confusing
if you still aren't 100 i would
recommend watching this part over again
however in layman's terms and for this
series
all i want you to be able to comprehend
is that dictionaries are built upon
these hash tables
and the keys in our key value pairs are
stored in these hash tables at
indexes which are determined by hash
functions
and if you can understand that you've
got a pretty good base for understanding
hash tables
now the final thing i want to talk to
you guys about in regards to hash tables
and the reason dictionary time
complexity equations are so funky
has to do with one small problem what
happens when we run
two different dictionary keys into a
hash function and the computer tells us
to store them at the same
index location for example
let's say we have two dictionary keys
with the strings
steven and sean and when we run both of
them through our hash function
the computer instructs us to store both
of them at the ninth index location
this should be impossible how are we
supposed to put both of them at index
location 9
this little problem is what's known as a
hash collision and can be solved one of
two ways
either open addressing or closed
addressing
with open addressing we just put the key
in some other index location
separate from the one returned to us by
the hash function
this is usually done by looking for the
next nil value in the table
i.e the closest location which contains
no key
so with our example the key steven would
get hash to the index location 9
mostly because it's a better name and
the inferior key sean would get stored
at index location 10
because it's the closest open location
available
this does make it harder to interact
with the data in our dictionary later on
and can lead to problems if we
eventually have a value which hashes to
the index location 10
which is why computer scientists
developed closed addressing
closed addressing uses linked lists to
chain together keys that result in the
same hash value
so the keys stephen and sean would get
stored together in a linked list
at index location 9. the main drawback
to this is that whenever we want to
interact with the values stored within a
key value pair
for either steven or sean we end up
having to look through the linked list
for that piece of data that we want
if there are 200 keys hash to one index
that's 200 keys we might have to search
through to find the one that we want
and that's not very good and with that
concludes our mini lesson on hash tables
now we can get back into dictionaries
and finally talk about their time
complexity equations
now remember back to the segment on time
complexity really quickly
back then i mentioned that for these
time complexity equations
we generally measure a data structure
based on its worst case scenario
but when it comes to dictionaries if we
are to assume the worst case scenario
things get a little outrageous we
basically end up assuming that our hash
function makes it so that every key
value pair ends up in the same index
meaning that each of our keys gets
stored in a linked list
assuming that closed addressing is being
used then
worst case scenario we have to assume
that every operation
functions how it would for accessing
searching for inserting or deleting from
a linked list
which if you remember is of n for all
four
this is of course preposterous and would
probably never happen with
the bare minimum decent hash function
which is why in addition to the worst
case scenario time complexity equations
i'll also go over the average time
complexity equations for these four
operations
now lucky for us they're all going to be
of one
this has to do with these hash functions
we talked about before
to access search for insert or delete a
key value pair from our dictionary
all we need to do is run that key
through our hash function
and it'll tell us what index in the hash
table to go to
in order to perform that operation
there's no time wasted
looking through preset indexes because
we the programmer generate the indexes
ourselves
and that's the power of the hash table
in the flesh
overall dictionaries are a very useful
data structure when it comes to computer
science for a few reasons
they differ from the rest in quite a few
big ways
the fact that they don't use a numerical
index to retrieve values
rather a preset key the notion that
those keys and the key value pairs can
be a range of types from strings to
integers
to chars and so on the implementation of
the hash table which allows for super
quick utilization
that is sure to come in handy in any
program that you write
in conclusion and overall the dictionary
is just a solid data structure that can
be used to fill in the gaps in your data
structure's knowledge
and with that we have now completed all
of the intermediate data structures if
you will
next we'll be moving on to trees and
tree based data structures
this is the point in the series where we
will be dropping our discussion on time
complexity equations
because if you thought that the
dictionary time complexity equations
were complicated with hash tables and
hash functions
trees and their many variants only
further complicate things
to the point where i no longer feel
comfortable including them in an
introductory course
we might mention that certain tree based
data structures are good for
accessing or searching but as for
discussions on all four time complexity
equations
dictionaries are where we leave things
with that being said
let's move on to the final few data
structures as we round out this
introduction to data structure series
next up on our list of data structures
is the tree
no not those big green things that
inhabit the outside world and that you
can climb on and get fruit from
rather the computer science data
structure which is way more fun in my
opinion
now before getting into trees we need to
talk about data structures in general
every data structure we've covered up
until this point has been stored
linearly
arrays stacks linked lists all of these
had a definitive start
and end to their data and you could
point them out easily
even the dictionary could be laid out in
such a way to be represented linearly
everything was so nice and neat and easy
to visualize
on the other hand trees store data
hierarchically
as opposed to linearly what does that
even mean
well besides being an extremely hard
word to pronounce
it's an alternative way to store data
that we're going to be using for the
remainder of this series
it's a little hard to visualize so i'm
going to start with an example
the most common real world example of
hierarchical data
would be a family tree each person would
be an
element of the family tree and
connections wouldn't be based on a
simple linear fashion
rather connections would be more
abstract and could lead to multiple
paths or branches
instead of just a single data point each
generation is ordered on a hierarchy
which is where the name comes from and
as you can see there's no definitive
end to the family tree sure there are
the ones at the bottom which you could
argue are the
ends of the family tree but which one of
them
is the definitive end there is none
another example could be a file
structure system on your computer
you'd have a base folder such as your
desktop
and then inside of that you might have
multiple other folders for different
types of information
and then inside of those you might have
more folders representing more types of
information
and then finally you would have your
documents
again it sets up a network of those
files on different levels
just like how we had with the family
tree trees
and the tree's many variants are all
dependent on storing data
hierarchically which of course finally
begs the question of what exactly a tree
is
well a tree is an abstract data
structure which consists of a series of
linked nodes connected together to form
a hierarchical representation of data
the actual information or data is stored
in these nodes
and the collection of nodes along with
the connections between them
is what's known as the tree this is sort
of like a linked list
only instead of each node only pointing
to one location
it has the option of pointing towards
multiple and also branching off on its
own
or pointing to no other nodes each of
the nodes in a tree can also be called
vertices
and the connections between vertices
what link two nodes together
are called edges now the free-flowing
structure of a tree
lends itself to a lot of different
configurations and with that comes a
plethora of terminology about certain
nodes
vertices and just the structure of a
tree in general
so what we're now going to do is go over
a lot of the terms associated with
specific nodes
based on where they are on the tree and
how they're connected to other nodes
while also visualizing the general
structure of a tree at the same time
okay let's start let's begin with the
things we've already talked about
a vertice is a certain node in a tree
and an edge is a connection between
nodes
the first new thing is that every tree
starts with what's known as a root node
this is always going to be the topmost
node of a tree
let's add a node with the integer 50 to
serve as our root node
next up let's connect two vertices to
our root node using two edges
these two nodes we just added are what's
known as child nodes
since they are both connected to the
node containing the integer 50.
child nodes can thus be defined as a
certain node which has an edge
connecting it to another node one level
above itself
vice versa the root node the vertices
containing the integer 50
is now what's called a parent node to
these two child nodes
thus we can define a parent node as any
node which has one or more
child nodes think back to our family
tree
if we were using people instead of
integers it'd make perfect sense that
the nodes directly connected to each
other have some sort of familial
relationship
let's continue on by adding two child
nodes to the node containing the integer
20.
when we do this the 30 node becomes a
parent node
and the two nodes we've just added
become child nodes
we have now branched off from the 20
node completely and that the two child
nodes
containing the integers 10 and 15
respectively
share no direct association with it
speaking of the 20 node since it does
not have any children
it is what's known as a leaf node or a
node in a tree which doesn't have any
child nodes
in this context the 10 and 15 nodes
would also be leaf nodes
finally let's add one more node as a
child of the 10 node
and there is our tree in all its glory
as a quick review the 50 node is the
root node
the 30 and 20 nodes are children of that
and the root node is thus the parent of
the 30 and 20 node
then the 10 and 15 nodes are children of
the 30 node
and the 30 node is thus a parent node to
both the 10 and 15 nodes
the 5 node is a child of the 10 node and
the 10 node is a parent to the 5 node
and finally the 5 15 and 20 nodes are
all leaf nodes
because they do not have any children as
you can see
one node or vertices on our tree can
have many different titles depending on
where it is in the tree
and what other nodes are connected to it
for example the 30 node is both
a parent node to the 10 and 15 nodes but
also a child of the 50 node
the 15 node is both a child of the 30
node
and also a leaf node as it has no
children
this terminology really comes in handy
when we start talking about trees which
contain
thousands of vertices and edges and the
data becomes very complicated to order
and maintain moving on the next two
pieces of terminology i want to go over
with you guys
are the height and depth of a tree the
height is a property of a particular
tree in and of itself
and the depth is a property of each
individual node contained within a tree
let's start with the height the height
of a tree is the number of edges
on the longest possible path down
towards a leaf
so in our tree example since the longest
path in our tree which leads to a leaf
is from the 50 node to the five node and
there are three edges in that path
the height of the tree would be three
the depth of a certain node is the
number of edges required to get from
that particular node to the root node
for example let's take our 30 node since
there's only one edge connecting it on
the way up to the root node
its depth would be one
for the 15 node however since there are
two edges which separate it from the
root node
the 15 node would have a depth of 2.
that's pretty much all you need to know
about the terminology associated with
trees and computer science
as a review we have the height and depth
obviously
then we have vertices edges root nodes
parent nodes and leaf nodes
now there's probably something that's
been scratching at the edge of your mind
for quite a while now
and that's why the heck are these called
trees they look nothing like trees
regular trees are not upside down like
this data structure would lead you to
believe
so who named trees and why well there's
actually a simple answer to this
the tree is said to have been invented
during the 1960s by two russian
inventors
and the last time that a computer
scientist got up from their chair
and went outside to actually see a tree
is rumored to have happened back in
1954.
ever since then it's been grinding away
at screens watching hours upon hours of
their favorite youtube channel
so please forgive them for their
confusion when it came to naming
conventions
they must have just forgotten trees
aren't upside down
now regular trees like the ones we just
created are great for storing
hierarchical data
but their power can really be heightened
when you start messing around with how
the actual data is stored within them
by imposing rules and restrictions on
what type of data is stored within a
tree
as well as where we can effectively use
the tree data structure to its full
potential
i could talk about the different types
of trees for a long time
so long that many of them are full
segments in this lecture
but for now i just want to cover one
popular variant
this will be a good introduction to how
trees can vary without simply diving
into a huge deviation from what we
already know
more specifically the tree variant i
want to talk to you guys about is the
binary search tree
a binary search tree is a simple
variation on the standard tree
which has three restrictions put on it
to help organize the data
the first is that a node can have at
most two children
this just helps make it easier to search
throughout the tree as we don't have to
spend time looking through each of the
eight children for a particular node
keeping it limited to two helps us do
this
the second restriction or property is
that for any given parent node
the child to the left has a value less
than or equal to itself
and the child to the right has a value
greater than or equal to itself
this might seem weird but it comes with
certain advantages and disadvantages
over using normal trees
which we'll get to in a bit the final
restriction put on binary search trees
is that no
two nodes can contain the same value and
this is just to prevent weird things
from happening when we begin searching
through the tree
now how do imposing these restrictions
on a tree actually help us
well the biggest advantage of binary
search trees
is that we're able to search through
them in logarithmic time
because there is a natural order to the
way that the data is stored
it makes it extremely easy to search for
a given value
logarithmic time if you remember back to
the segment on time complexity
is the equation in which we get more
bang for our buck the greater number of
elements
or no nodes we have in our data
structure
it works like this all we have to do
when searching
is tell the computer to go left if the
value we're searching for
is less than the current node and right
if it's greater than the current node
we can then wash rinse and repeat this
strategy until we find our desired node
this makes binary search trees really
popular for storing large quantities of
data that need to be easily searchable
of course this also translates to
inserting deleting and accessing
elements within the data structure
but for the most part searching
efficiency is what really sets the
binary search tree
apart from the rest stepping away now
from binary search trees and into trees
in general
let's talk about common uses for them in
computer science
the most common uses for trees in
computer science include storing data
with a naturally hierarchical structure
these are like the examples we touched
upon at the beginning of the segment
data sets such as file structure systems
family trees
a company's corporate structure all of
these could be stored and implemented
using the tree data structure
very easily these are all general
examples though
as i mentioned before when we put
restrictions on trees
like in the case of the binary search
tree we can expand its uses even further
a tree's base structure is incredibly
useful and it can be modified in so many
ways which only add to its functionality
one of these ways is through what's
known as a try and is the next data
structure on our agenda
so stay tuned for that
next up we'll be talking about another
one of the special trees with
restrictions
we just finished discussing the binary
search tree and
with that we mentioned how trees usually
become even more useful once you start
setting restrictions on how and where
the data can be stored within them
well a try is another one of these
special trees which have special
restrictions put in place to help store
the data in an effective manner
this data structure is often overlooked
since it's only used in specific
situations
but without the use of tries within
those specific situations
some important features of your
computing life would be a whole lot
harder
so we get it stephen a try is a special
tree with restrictions
but what are those restrictions and how
can they help us
well let's start with the basics a try
is a tree-like data structure whose
nodes
store letters of an alphabet in the form
of characters
we can carefully construct this tree of
characters in such a way which allows us
to quickly retrieve words in the form of
strings
by traversing down a certain path of the
try
these are also sometimes called digital
trees or prefix trees by the computer
science community
but we'll be calling them tries for
today's lecture
tries are used in the retrieval of data
in the form of words
which is actually where the name tri
comes from as it's
smack dab in the middle of the word
retrieval
essentially in layman's terms we use
tries to retrieve words extremely fast
by traversing down a tree of store
characters
this is hard to explain without actually
showing you so let's do an example of
what a try might actually look like
now just like with a tree every try is
going to start with a root note
only in our case that root node will be
empty with either some null value or a
blank string
now also stored within this node will be
a set of references
all stored within an array these
references are set to null at the
beginning of the tri's existence
but can be slowly filled with references
to other notes
for example let's say we were creating a
try to store words that start with the
letter d
the root node would contain an array
which contains a reference to a node
containing the character d
signifying the start of our word now
imagine for a second
that this d node also has an array
containing references
only this time it contains references
that point towards all characters in the
english alphabet which serve as the
first two characters of a word in the
english dictionary
so d a serves as the first two
characters in a lot of english words
such as dad or dao or dab if you really
want to go that far
and so the array contained within the d
node would hold a reference to an
a node now since there are no english
words which start with db
that i know of we wouldn't have a
reference to a b node
since we know we will never have to
retrieve a word from our try
which starts with db we continue this
process for all letters in the alphabet
only including references to characters
which serve as the first
two characters in an english word but
that is a lot to visualize
so for now let's just put up on the
screen two nodes that this first d
node would point towards more
specifically
the node we've already added the a node
as well as the e node
now to continue building our try we
would simply repeat this process for all
of the nodes that this d
node points towards so we'd store
pointers in the a node which would point
towards characters and the english
alphabet
that serve as the first three characters
of a word in the english dictionary
so you'd have a b a d a y and many many
more nodes as well
but we're just going to stick with those
three for now for e
you'd have pointers which point towards
nodes containing characters like
n and w obviously there'd be more nodes
than the ones shown on your screen right
now
for all levels of nodes but what we've
created here is a very simple try
as you can see it's exactly like i said
it was in the beginning
a tree-like data structure which stores
characters that can be used to make
words by traversing down paths
as we travel down different paths of our
tree we can make different words
dab dad day down the one path
and then and do down the other
by following the nodes downwards we can
easily build strings of words
which you'll learn towards the end of
the episode can be extremely useful
we can even take this process further by
having one path contain multiple strings
for example if we isolate the den path
we could continue the process to go on
to words like dense
or denver or dent the list goes on and
on
we wouldn't have to just stop at the
word den since den
is also a prefix for numerous other
words and that's what makes storing data
in the character format so useful one
path down a try
can represent multiple words depending
on where you stop along the process
this does provide a bit of a problem for
computer scientists though
how do we know when a word has ended
let's take the denver path as an example
if we wanted to retrieve the word den
from this try
how would we know to stop at the end
node and not continue along to denver
there is actually a pretty simple fix to
this and it's known as flagging
we simply mark the end of the word by
having it also point towards a flag
to let the computer know that the end of
a word has occurred
so in our denver example not only would
the n
nodes array contain pointers to
whichever characters follow it
it would also contain a pointer to a
node with a flag
to tell the computer to stop there in
this case i've just chosen a period as
the flag
this way we can construct tries in such
a way wherein
each word is marked by an ending point
and the different words that may branch
off from the prefix can continue to use
that word as a prefix
in whichever retrieval program ends up
getting used
okay so now it's time to talk about the
general use cases of a try
if you remember back to the beginning of
this segment i said that the use cases
for a try were limited but extremely
effective
and now we're going to talk about what
that statement means
now have you ever used the auto complete
feature on your iphone
or spell check on a google doc because
if so you have already experienced the
overwhelming power of tries
as they are used for both of these
extremely useful features
this mainly has to do with the fact that
for big programs like ios or google docs
they're not just storing a try
containing a few words or even all the
words starting with a certain letter
like we tried to replicate
they're storing the entire english
dictionary
storing the entire dictionary in a try
seems like a tall task
but it can and has been done each node
would simply have 26 nodes connected to
it
and those 26 would have as many nodes
connected to them
as needed and so on and so on
now i can hear you asking in the
comments how does this help us with
autocomplete and spell check
well let's say you're typing out a word
for the sake of this video let's say
it's the word subscribe
you start with the s at this point the
computer has
already eliminated 95 of words that you
could be typing
we know it's not going to be a word
which starts with n or with
a or o or h or l etc etc
then you type the letter u and bam
another 95
of possible options get deleted with
each character you type you eliminate
millions of possible words that you
could be working towards
using this fact as well as popularity
data which could also be stored within
the node
the computer can start making educated
guesses using that information
as well as context from previous words
to make a suggestion as to what word
you're trying to type out
the ai that works this feature is
immensely complicated
but it is backed by the tri data
structure and helps autocomplete work
easily on your phone
as for spell check well when you spell a
word wrong
a spell checking algorithm can use the
root of your word
and compare it against try data to make
an educated guess
as to what you were trying to spell the
slightly misspelled words will usually
have a similar path from the root of the
try
if you accidentally type chocolata
instead of chocolate
the computer can take the first few
characters of the word you typed in
correctly
and see where you may have gone wrong
basically by comparing the misspelled
word
to certain paths of the dictionary try
it can pretty accurately detect which
word you were meaning to say
and correct you accordingly
so there you have it the try like i said
it is often underrated in the computer
science world since it can only be used
in certain situations
but as i hope this segment has shown you
those situations are still important
nonetheless we are nearing the end of
our introduction to data structure
series now
only two more left before we part ways
so stay tuned because now we're going to
talk about heaps
now back in our segment on trees we
talked about the binary search tree
a special type of tree which has a few
properties
each node can only have two children the
child to the left must have a value less
than the parent node
and the child to the right must have a
value greater than the parent node
and also no two nodes could contain the
same value
well a heap is sort of like this but a
little bit different
more specifically by definition a heap
is a special tree where
all parent nodes compare to their
children nodes in some specific way
by being either more extreme or less
extreme
i.e greater than or less than this
specific way
determines where the data is stored and
is usually dependent on the root node's
value
there are two different methodologies
generally used in computer science
and they are known as min heaps and max
heaps
in a min heap the value at the root node
of the tree
must be the minimum amongst all of its
children
and this fact must be recursively the
same for any and all
parent nodes contained within the heap
so each parent node must have a value
lower than all of its children nodes
as you can see from our example on the
screen now
10 is the root node and also the minimum
value in the tree
in addition to this fact if we pick any
parent node on the tree
and look at its children and their
children and so on
the parent node will have the lowest
value of the mall
take 14 for example its value is less
than
26 31 44 35 and 33.
this must be the case for every single
subtree which is contained within the
heap
max heaps on the other hand are the
exact opposite
in a max heap the value at the root note
of the tree must be the maximum amongst
all of its children
and this fact must be recursively the
same for any and all parent nodes
contained within the heap
if you take a look at the example max
heap we have on the screen now
again you'll see that this is the case
44 is the root node and also the largest
value within the heap
if you take a look at say the subtree
which is parented by the 35 node
you'll see that 35 is the maximum value
amongst all nodes in that subtree
greater than both 19 and 27.
when we store data like this in a heap
whether that be a
min heap or a max heap it makes it
extremely easy to insert or remove from
this lends itself to a lot of useful
implementations within computer science
now to show you this i'd like to build
an example max heap
the one which has the greatest integer
stored in the root node
for the sake of keeping things simple
let's pull up an array of seven elements
with integers ranging from 0 to 100
and simply convert it into a heap one
element by one
this can be done in a few easy steps
step one is we add the first integer in
as the root node
so 70 would get inserted into our tree
then we add another node to the tree in
the bottom leftmost position available
so we would first insert a node as the
child of the root node
to the left for our heap this means
adding the integer 4
as a child of the 70 node the final step
is to recursively go
up the heap and swap nodes if necessary
now when we say if necessary we mean
that if the node we just added
is more extreme either greater than or
less than the node above it depending on
the type of heap that we're trying to
create
we swap them to maintain order amongst
the heap
since we're building a max heap and 70
is greater than
4 no swaps are necessary in this case
now we just simply repeat steps 2 and 3
until we've built our heap
so next we want to add the integer 90
and since the leftmost slot on the tree
is already taken by our 4 node
the right slot ends up being the
leftmost location on our tree
so we insert it there and then since 90
is greater than 70
we actually end up swapping the 90 and
70 nodes
doing this helps keep the max heap
property intact
where every level is greater than the
one below it
let's keep going next we add 45 to the
heap
now since we've run out of space on the
second level we move on to a third level
and add 45 as a child of the 4 node
then we compare it to 4 which it is
greater than
so we swap the nodes now we have to
compare this node to the node above it
again
because remember we recursively go up
the tree until we reach the root
or don't need to swap now 45
is not greater than 90 so it stays put
where it's at
next up we add 23 as another child of
the 45
node only this time on the right side
we compare and since it's not greater
than 45
we keep it as is moving on we next
insert 76 into the tree
as a child of the 70 node then we can
pair and swap the 76 and 70 nodes as 76
is indeed greater than 70.
we then compare 76 and 90 and since 90
is greater than 76
keep the 76 node in place for now
the next node we add is the 100 node we
compare it to the 76 node and see that
it's greater
so it gets swapped and then we compare
it again
this time to the 90 node and since it's
also greater than that integer
it gets swapped yet again to become the
root node signifying it is the greatest
node in the heap
as you can see it's a pretty simple
concept you add a node and then keep
trying to swap
up until the node you've added is in its
rightful place
deleting from heap is also pretty simple
at least in our case
this is because the type of deletion i
want to talk about
is just the process of removing the root
node from the heap
and you'll see why later on to delete
the root node from a heap
you follow a three-step process step one
is actually removing the root node from
our heap
so in our case we delete the 100 node
what you do with it is up to the
programmer you can return it back to the
user
store it somewhere else print it out etc
etc
either way then step two is replacing it
with the node
furthest to the right in this case it
would be the 76
node finally for step 3
we do what's known as a heapify to fix
up the heap
we start with the root node and compare
it to its children to see if we need to
swap any values
so for the 76 node we compare it to its
two child nodes
and since 76 is less than 90 we end up
swapping those too
then we wash rinse repeat for every sub
tree that we have so on the right side
we swapped 90 with 76 but since 76
remains the greatest integer
on that particular subtree it stays in
the same spot
on the left side we didn't change
anything but 45 is still the greatest
integer
amongst the three nodes in that subtree
so no swapping is necessary on that
branch of the heap
and so we've completed our heapify and
all heap properties are still intact
that is inserting and deleting nodes in
a nutshell
now let's talk about how we can use this
to our advantage
heaps are most commonly used in the
implementation of heap
sort heapsort is a sorting algorithm
which takes in a list of elements
builds them into a min or max heap and
then removes the root node continuously
to make a sorted list
because heaps always start with the
minimum or maximum value contained
within them
at the root node we're able to simply
just remove the root node over and over
again
keepifying the data structure after
every pass and after every element has
been removed
we are left with a sorted list on your
screen you'll see we have
an unsorted list on the left in the
middle we've inserted all of those
integers
and in doing so created a max heap and
then finally on the right we have
continuously removed those elements from
the root node
into a now sorted list heapsort is a
really cool algorithm
and will be part of our upcoming series
on sorting algorithms
which is kicking off very soon so if
you're interested in that
make sure you subscribe to our channel
so that you don't miss it a link will be
in the description below
another extremely popular use of heaps
is through the implementation of
priority queues
priority queues are an advanced data
structure which your computer uses to
designate
tasks and assign computing power based
on how urgent a certain matter is
think of it like a line at the hospital
you wouldn't want your line to follow a
regular cue methodology which implements
first
in first out since then you could have
patients with extremely urgent matters
like heart attacks
waiting behind people coming in for a
routine checkup
in the same way you wouldn't want your
computer to update an application before
it finishes
rendering a video otherwise your entire
progress would be lost
priority queues take care of all the
task scheduling done by your computer
and the heap data structure is used as
the backing system for it
and with that ends our discussion on
heaps to review
they are a special tree in which each
level contains nodes with values
more extreme either greater than or less
than
the nodes on the level above it next up
is
unfortunately the last segment in the
series on yet another tree based data
structure
the graph the graph is arguably the most
dynamic data structure
in our introduction to data structure
series and an absolute banger to go out
on
so let's just hop right into it before
we get into the nitty gritty details i
first want to do a short little exercise
visualize for a second a few of your
favorite places to eat on a map around
your town
for me personally it'd be places like
five guys chick-fil-a
panera wawa and dominos now imagine for
a second that you
are ravished absolutely starving and so
your plan
is obviously to drive around to each of
your favorite places to eat
and order an ungodly amount of food from
each location
each food location has a few possible
paths going to
and from it and so we add those to the
map as well
now you can see what we now have looks
like a network of delicious foods
we can start anywhere and all we have to
do is make sure to hit all five
you may not know it but what we've
essentially done here is set up a simple
graph
basically graphs are composed of pieces
of information
like the restaurants and the paths that
run between them
of course this is just generally by
definition
graphs are a non-linear data structure
consisting of nodes and edges
there are a finite set of these nodes or
vertices which are connected by edges
nodes and edges should be familiar to
you if you watch the segment on trees
the big difference between trees and
graphs however is that with a tree
we had a specific starting point sure
there were multiple paths down the tree
that
branched off from the initial starting
point but you always had to begin at the
root node
in contrast with a graph there is no
specified starting point
we can begin from any node and traverse
to any node
just like how in our food example we
were able to start at any restaurant
graphs are a huge concept and escape the
bounds of computer science
often being used in many places you
wouldn't even think of
but before we get into anything crazy
though like the difference between a
directed or undirected graph
or acyclic versus cyclical graphs let's
get down the basics
now every graph is composed of these
nodes or vertices
and the edges that connect them let's
pull up a sample graph really quickly
and talk about it
we represent graphs visually like this a
lot because it makes it way easier to
comprehend
but notationally wise a graph actually
looks like this
which is much harder to comprehend so
let's break it down
first we have the vertices set which
contains a comma separated list of all
vertices within the graph
that's the simple part each comma
separated value simply represents a node
within the graph
then we have the edge set which is a
little bit more complicated
each element of the edge set is an
ordered pair which describes
relationships between
nodes for example the first one
describes a relationship between the six
and four nodes the fifth indicates a
relationship between the five and two
nodes
and so on using these two sets we're
able to visualize a graph pretty easily
by laying down both the information and
the connections that fall between them
one final thing i want to mention about
the basics of graphs
is about the relationships that occur
between two nodes
if we have an edge which connects two
different vertices they are known as
adjacent to one another
so for example the five node would be
adjacent to the
four two and one nodes
okay now that we have the basics down i
now want to jump into the different
attributes that a particular graph might
have
starting with directed versus undirected
an undirected graph is one in which the
direction you traverse the nodes
isn't important this is most prominently
indicated by a lack of arrows pointing
to specific nodes
such was the case with our first example
graph or even the food example from the
beginning of the episode
we can hop between nodes or even go back
and forth between them
without problem a good way to visualize
undirected graphs is like a network of
friends on facebook
where each edge indicates a friendship
if you will
because of the fact that when somebody
accepts to be your friend on facebook
you are both added to each other's
friends list the friendship goes both
ways and direction is unimportant
in contrast a directed graph is one in
which the direction you traverse the
nodes
is important this is usually indicated
by
arrows representing which nodes a
certain node is able to traverse to
the edges could point both ways but they
don't have to
it's very possible the edge only points
one way
a good way to visualize directed graphs
is by thinking them as a network of
friends on instagram
sure i can follow famous celebrity will
smith
but the odds that he follows me back
fairly low
and so in that case the relationship
only goes one way
undirected and directed graphs both have
their uses
as we discussed with the social media
example both provide different
functionality which will be useful to
you
in your computer science journey just
like the next type of property a graph
can be classified as
either cyclic or acyclic
a cyclic graph is one which contains a
path from at least
one node back to itself so you can see
by the example on your screen now that
the four node leads to the three node
which
leads to the two node which leads to the
one node which finally leads back to the
four node
forming a cycle essentially we're able
to follow at least
one path that eventually leads back to
our starting point
a small thing to note here is that all
undirected graphs
end up being cyclical the bi-directional
nature of nodes within
undirected graphs theoretically forms a
cycle between
any two nodes so judging by that logic
all undirected graphs end up being
cyclic
an acyclic graph is one which contains
no path from any one node
which leads back in on itself this
property can really only apply to
undirected graphs like we mentioned
previously
essentially this means that for any
given node there is no path which will
eventually lead back to itself
undirected directed cyclic and acyclic
are all properties we can use to
classify types of graphs based on their
nodes
but the last property i want to talk
about actually applies to the edges of a
graph instead and it's the process
of waiting weighting the edges of a
graph means associating a numerical
value with each edge
often called the cost of that edge each
weight represents some property of the
information you are trying to convey
for example again going back to our food
location scenario
since the information that we're trying
to convey is a good route which takes us
to each location
a good weight for our edges in that
scenario could be the distance between
nodes
this comes in handy a lot especially
with navigation
such as the case with our restaurant
example as we of course always want to
find the path of least
cost or weight between the different
nodes
so there are the major properties of a
heap that the different nodes and edges
can have
directed or undirected cyclic or acyclic
and weighted or unweighted there are a
couple more
obscure ones out there but those six are
what we will be covering today
combining these three properties
together leaves us with numerous types
of graphs which all have different
strengths and weaknesses
it would take a while to talk about each
of these and their implementations
so for now i'll just pick out three
types of graphs which are used in the
most popular cases
now probably the most famous
implementation of the graph data
structure
is through the undirected cyclical graph
with weighted edges
this one gets a lot of views especially
through its implementation
in dijkstra's shortest path algorithm
this algorithm given a graph and a
source vertex within that graph compiles
a list of the shortest possible paths
from that source vertex to all other
nodes
as you might be able to tell just from
its description this has a multitude of
uses across the entire tech world
google uses this algorithm for google
maps it's used in the process of ip
routing and it can even be implemented
in telephone networks
another type of graph which you probably
use quite often
is the unweighted cyclical graphs both
undirected and directed
as these make up the follower systems of
a majority of social media websites
we already talked about these in the
cases of facebook which would use a
cyclical representation
as well as instagram which would use an
acyclical representation
however this example encapsulates much
more than just those two
snapchat twitter tick tock even
all these platforms can represent your
follower following base through a graph
and often times do facebook even has a
graph api
which you can use to interact with the
models that they use to illustrate
each user's web of friends
as you can see graphs and there are many
different forms provide a lot of the
functionality that you interact with in
everyday life
contributing to almost any facet of the
internet
and with that concludes our discussion
on graphs as a review
a graph is a data structure which is
represented by a set of nodes and
edges these come together to form a
visualization of data
whether that data be food locations on a
map or friends on social media
the different types of graphs provide a
multitude of implementations in computer
science
and with that concludes our introduction
to data structure series
after around 3 hours and 12 data
structures you should now have the basic
knowledge to take with you as you
continue along your computer science
journey
and if you've made it this long you
obviously liked what you saw
so stick around for an extra 30 seconds
while i'll pitch to you
why you should check out my personal
channel
now i introduce myself at the beginning
of the series but again
my name is stephen i'm an 18 year old
computer science student who runs a
youtube channel called null pointer
exception with one of my good friend
sean
we've been producing content like this
seriously for about four months now and
have grown a good audience of around 800
subscribers which we couldn't be happier
about
if you'd like to join us you can check
out our channel linked in the
description below
and just try out a few of our other
videos and if you like what you see
you can subscribe that ends my pitch
and with that i have nothing else to say
i hope you have enjoyed this series as
much as i've enjoyed making it
thank you so much for watching